all right you're you're good to go okay
thank
you okay good morning after some
technical delays we're getting ready to
start today's
hearings um I'm going to read the
chairman script I would advise everyone
to remember that all the mics are on if
you have a personal advice signed in
Zoom please turn it off or turn off your
microphone so we don't pick up
feedback
so as chair of the house Edna committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate at
contemporaneously during the meeting
through Zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by Zoom platform or
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar of the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call 603
271-3600 or email
HCS
l. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking
the roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law if
you could take the role
please representative
Allegro present
oh representative
Bailey representative
fellows present Home
Alone president represent
F I am present at home in Rochester my
wife and granddaughter are in the
house representative
goalie I am present at my uh residence
in Bethlehem uh with my wife Heather in
the house representative groa I'm here
home alone in my
office representative
JD
you have to unmute
yourself haven't press the space bar if
he's on a computer representative Judy
press and hold the space bar on your
computer
okay you hear me now yes okay I'm here
alone
okay thank you sorry about that it's
okay representative
lanzara can't hear you
I you're unmuted
but
try it
again who's here perhaps the sound could
be turned up I don't know I'm gonna just
Mark you in but maybe we can try to fix
this before in case you want to ask any
questions come back
to I know he's there representative leas
leus
leus I'm here in the committee room
thank
you representative
O'Brien I am present I am in uh Nash uh
and I got the grandchildren all over the
house okay representative Maguire is is
out for the meeting is that right uh
she's at the chair meeting yeah okay
so she probably
returned okay representative
Pearson Steve piar I am here can you
hear me yes in the committee room thank
you representative
Roy I'm
here representative
saso I'm here alone in my
house representative
Schmidt I am present at the hand at the
home of a friend in Portsmouth she is
currently in the room with me but uh
will not be hear from most of the
hearing representative
Shu I am present at home and my cat's
here that's
it representative
Schultz I am at home and my husband will
be in and out of the
room representative sitech is expected
at 10 so I'll mark him in at that time
representative
yakubovich present at home alone in the
room thank you roll call is
completed uh thank you representative
gr at this time I'm GNA open the public
hearing on HB
425 and I'm going
to me representative over has a panelist
to introduce
Bill representative over can you hear me
you are recognized you are
muted thank you Mr chairman I can hear
you and I can hear committee members
hb25 is a very simple
bill I submitted written testimony to
each Committee Member a week ago which
included Amendment
202-277-6004 new the purpose of this
bill is to introduce to state law the
actual jobs being done by these two
people commissioner goule is here this
morning he can answer your questions
about the need for cyber security and
why we have to have information
technology that is secure throughout our
state this bill requires no additional
financial support it is cost neutral it
could easily EB ought to pass as amended
with Amendment
[Music]
202-277-6004
you hear me
now okay the chair recognizes Mr valay
you
are ready to
go thank you Mr chair and the members of
the committee uh my name is Dennis G I'm
the uh commissioner for the Department
of Information
Technology um I'm at home um my wife is
in the house uh but not in the room with
me um uh as representative Ober said the
the main purpose of this this bill was
to really um to bring into statute um a
couple of items that had been um we'
been operating under executive order
from back in Governor hasson's day um
there the cyber security advisory
committee and and the New Hampshire
cyber integration
Center the advisory committee is our way
to communicate with um folks around uh
all of the branches of government we
have membership from all the branches as
well as the um as a a representative
from each executive branch
agency that entity um uh helps us
develop cyber security policy but we
also communicate and and um and uh find
out the impacts of policy before we
implement it by through discussion with
that group we then take any new policies
that we might be creating through the
CAC and bring them to the it Council um
where uh we could ratify um it council
is defined in RSA 21r as the governing
body for uh the executive branch it
agency Department of Information
Technology so it's really a very
effective committee that we think we
should just continue so rather having it
exist under um under executive order
we'd like to have it in statute uh
similarly uh the cyber security um the
NH kick or the um cyber security
integration Center is the hub for um
watching and reacting to cyber incidents
in the state of New Hampshire um it's
been very effective U over its time and
again it it existed and was formed under
executive order and and uh we'd like to
have it in statute most recently the um
the uh NH kick or the Cyber integration
Center was very involved in um you know
watching and managing the the very large
number of attacks or attempted attacks
against state government uh by uh
foreign entities both during the
elections as well as um as well as
associated with um our covid-19
activities trying to take advantage of
people um in this in this time of
emergency that concludes my testimony
and I'm available for
questions uh thank you commissioner does
anyone have uh questions of the
commissioner I see representative Shu
you are recognized to ask a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
commissioner um I'm curious uh you say
that you actually have people doing jobs
right now these two positions are the
positions in the current state budget um
and at this same pay
level uh yes um the positions exist and
are filled and um have fairly recently
gone through the um The JCC to uh to
level set those positions they are in
the they're in our current budget and
they're also in the the 2223 budget as
proposed thank you you're welcome
any further questions to the
commissioner there being none thank you
very much Mr commissioner thank you all
take
care is there anyone else wishing to
speak I I I've raised my hand Mr
chairman I I have a question uh uh go
ahead thank you thank you very much uh
let me turn my camera on so you can see
me uh is the Comm still on the line he
yes okay so Mr commissioner as you know
from having been before us numerous
times uh in the past this committee has
been very supportive not only of the
efforts of your department but your uh
of your oversight uh and I'm wondering
uh whether there's whether they're going
to hear any further Witnesses uh
especially anyone in opposition to this
uh which seems to me to be a very
straightforward Common Sense bill which
I will support but I'm just wondering
whether there's any any downside to it
that we have yet to hear
of um thank you for the question sir um
I'm not aware of any um in fact I think
that the folks that um have participated
in in the the CAC the cyber security
advisory committee have been very
pleased um historically if you looked
back prior to implementing that entity
and the way we have it there were
occasions where we would Implement cyber
policy that that hadn't really been as
vetted as well as we can vet it now and
the real D downside to that is you know
implementing something that's good cyber
policy but also stops legitimate
business or state you know citizen
service activities so what we really
strive to do is have good cyber security
policy as in in a way that isn't going
to negatively affect affect our citizen
service Mission so I I'm not aware of
any detractors up for this followup Mr
chair
yes go ahead thank you uh and
commissioner uh you know in the past
when you've been before us we've always
asked you what the status of uh the
ongoing attacks against uh the state uh
are and uh are we keeping a breast of
the effective uh defense that we've been
engaged in uh in view of the fact that
the technology is constantly evolving uh
are holding our
own thank you for the question um we
we've been doing a number of things
lately and one of them is um we we did
actually conduct um a a uh Statewide
executive branch cyber risk assessment
um that was funded with um Capital that
um that um was approved in the the
current budget um and we've uh done some
some mitigation steps there and we
continue to do mitigation steps
associate with the findings of that um
comprehensive cyber risk assessment
we've also done some specific things
around um activities that have been
occurring in covid so early in covid
recovery and response we actually um
were benefited from guard activation
cyber Warriors they called them so we
actually had some really great expertise
come and help us um you know keep up
with things during that really that
large surge of activity that occurred
early on and we continue to see a very
you know an a heightened an increase
amount of activity uh as it relates to
um two primary things one is the know
attempts to get into the
network um and and in nowadays when they
get into the network it's mostly for
economic benefit you know to to uh
promote ransomware that would could then
be used to to get money and the other
the other area that we see a lot of
activity on is um the the the idea of um
diverting funds for example go getting
into somebody's payroll uh payroll
account in um changing their direct
deposit number that that's also has
happened in in um uh It's associated
with um identity theft usually or
fishing attacks where somebody actually
gets um you know gets your login and
password gets you to give them your
login and password and then you go in
and divert the funds that's happen and
we've seen that happen around the state
um not in state government but in local
governments with payroll systems and we
you you've heard about it happening in
in unemployment systems all around the
country um so we really must remain
constantly Vigilant um one thing we're
doing right now is um we're focused on
those Key Systems that we need to to do
uh to keep the vaccination effort going
so we're actually having our the folks
who did the Cyber risk R assessment
we're having them look at the Key
Systems that we use to run our our
vaccination um mission in the state and
make sure that we didn't miss anything
so it's really a proactive we're
spending some some of that um some of
that Capital cyber Capital to
proactively look at um those systems
that we're using for
vaccination thank you very much and uh
please continue your excellent
administration of this uh Department
thank you so much thank you uh for your
support uh members of the committee I
appreciate it representative fellows you
have a
question um yes uh thank you Mr chair
for the commissioner can you just tell
me really briefly um what sort of
resources and Personnel the extent to to
which you use resources and Personnel to
help the municipalities with
security thank you for the question um
there there is actually another um bill
in the
um that that will be um considered that
um does a couple things with the
municipalities but I'll start by saying
that we what we've done recently is
formed an informal public private
partnership with primex who who carries
most of the insurance all the insurance
for um schools and uh insurance for most
of the the political subdivisions and
that so that's um with the Department of
Information Technology primex uh the
National Guard and then HRA Municipal
Association and Emergency Management in
the state and what we're doing is we're
we're actually hosting a cyber Summit in
March where we're going to introduce a
bunch of Concepts to anybody that wants
attend we're going to do it virtually we
had intended to do it um in person back
in May which obviously we didn't do so
now we're hosting a virtual session in
March uh additional things we're doing
is we're we're looking for um on a state
level we're we're seeking some Homeland
Security grant funding so that we could
offer free cyber um um cyber awareness
training to all
employees and and uh of of entities in
our political subdivisions to include
schools and uh and the the operations of
their governments so um I I think
there's a decent chance we'll get that
money and we'll be able to implement
offer free cyber awareness training and
on a national level we're working to
support and legislation um on the
national level that would create a cyber
grant program for state governments and
we believe and and hope and will try to
influence that grant program so that um
There are rules about money flowing down
to political subdivisions and not all
staying at the state government level so
we're doing lots of things I have a a
vision that over
time uh we have a really strong cyber
disruption plan that was developed with
Homeland Security money grant money in
New Hampshire for a state my vision
would be to have a that plan um
Encompass and engulf not engulf that
sounds too controlling but Encompass the
political subdivision such that if we
had a cyber incident anywhere um we all
knew how to react to it and we all knew
how to work together to help that entity
whether it's a school or a or a town or
a police department or a fire department
recover as quickly as
possible thank you that sounds really
great I'm working hard on it it's a it's
a passion of mine so thanks for the
question okay thank you
commissioner um any more
questions there being none I'm going to
go ahead and close the public hearing on
HB
425 and I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
[Music]
591 and I going to recognize the prime
sponsor representative abami in
second representative Roy I mean before
we begin has anyone else entered the lob
room with you that is not on that either
representative Maguire or representative
scitec are they there uh yes
representative scitec just joined us
he's setting up and and representative
Maguire is still not there correct that
is correct would you like representative
scitec to take over the minutes is he
ready to take over the minutes for house
building 49
591 he says that he
is that's fine then please please thank
you um looking for
there he
is representative abramy you are
recognized toip
bill you are
muted you hear me
now yes please proceed thank you very
much uh for the
record represent could you could you um
get closer to your mic or something we
can't hear you very well
let me just check uh I'm going to check
my settings on the audio settings here
give me one
second
uh no I have to settings say I'm I'm I'm
at
maximum okay just get as close as you
can okay I I'll I'll kind of reach in
here let's click off this a
second okay uh for the record du State
Rep pamy Rockingham 19 Strat
I'm here to introduce House Bill
591 the Genesis of this bill goes back
to last term when we I guess your
committee and my committee were trying
to uh come up with a license and license
fee for vape
shops the license was to be included
within the tobacco product statutes
which really are embedded within the
alcohol
statutes my ways the Means Committee in
doing the re its review discovered along
with the enforcement division of of the
commission that the whole category of
stores that did not sell alcohol
products was not being was only being
charged $6 for a license I repeat only
being charged $6 for a
license and this is the mistake and this
mistake as we kind of tentacle back uh
snakes back to when the uh tobacco
products fell within the Liquor Division
uh bunch of years ago so we we had
identified then right now there are
currently 1902
stores uh in this
category uh an an example would be
dollar stores uh they sell tobacco
products but they don't sell beer or
wine and they are only paying $6 for a
license to sell
cigarettes and in those
192 are because we we we were successful
in getting uh the vape shops license
uh but uh there must be around 15 or
those or so uh someone out of business
because of the the virus uh but but they
they are only paying $6 for a license so
we we tried to fix this last year and it
it died in the Senate uh when they you
know all those hundreds of bills didn't
make it through the
Senate so you say why the $6 how did
that happen well grocery stores
convenience stores drug stores and
others who have licens to sell beer or
and wine or beer or wine pay less uh uh
pay a license fee if they also sell
tobacco products they pay only an
additional $6 for a tobacco license so
it turns out the only thing on the books
is this $6 for a tobacco license nowhere
else in the statutes do you find uh a
fee or uh a fee for a license that's uh
for a store uh that that just sells
tobacco okay and what we try to do with
the fees and Ways and Means is to make
them kind of uh match up with the amount
of effort on the part of the enforcement
division to do their work and obviously
$6 was not
enough so this bill fixes that if you go
to uh line 10 to 13 of uh of the bill
you will see that we came up with a a li
a fee that kind of matches up with the
combination license for
alcohol now the other thing this bill
does uh is asks for two two new
investigators positions which were our
sworn
officers okay sworn officers to be paid
uh in part from the new
fees uh this is on page two lines 27 to
36 and page three lines one and
two so um
if you spend any time in these
statutes you'll find that they are very
confusing and need to be streamlined
this is just a comment that we
discovered in ways that means that
recodification this is an aside just a
recodification of these statutes was
probably not a bad thing to be done as a
maybe jointly between our
committees uh uh and the and the first
ones to agree with that is the Liquor
Commission that they're very
confusing but what we tried to do in
this bill is fix one thing was and
that's the uh
that when we were doing our work we
couldn't match up the license with the
fee okay and so the bill the bill also
does that's the third thing that the
bill does and you'll see a lot of you
see why is this bill so long it's
because that was our attempt to to fix
that so this past Ways and Means last
year I think we got a from from your
committee uh and again like I said uh it
passed the unanimous in our committee
our committee in ways and means and this
was the casualty of the Senate again uh
last year so Mr chair my understanding
is that and and I I think we got this
from uh chair Maguire that this bill is
going to be coming to Ways and Means and
that her interest was not in the the the
fees per se that she would let Ways and
Means deal with that if you you indeed
pass this bill
through um so is that your understanding
uh U Mr chair chairman Roy yes okay
so so but I emailed uh the committee and
um um U chairman Maguire and the
committee an
amendment in the last couple of months
I've been working with the the uh
enforcement division offline
uh because when we we looked at the
language we let me let me tell you the
three reasons for the amendment working
with them it does tighten up the the the
language even more to ensure that anyone
who has a current liquor license uh this
is on premises off- premises licenses
we're talking about uh do not have to
pay the tobac the full tobacco license
they continue to pay the $6 so we made
sure that that language was tightened up
to make sure that only
happens um understand over time you know
uh um you know convenience stores uh
grocery stores and drug stores have the
combination Li most of them do but now
some of the drugstores don't carry
tobacco products because of health
reasons so so it's important that we
have a separate tobacco license for well
those 192 two stores that we were
talking about first as well as U making
sure that the
$6 uh doesn't get applied to you say
well why don't we just include the WRA
the tobacco license into the liquor
license no we can't do that
so so the second thing it does is the pl
U it changes the fee uh in the original
Bell down a bit to being more in line
with the retail wine license um and that
was done after consultation with the
Liquor Commission The Liquor Commission
folks and the third thing it does is it
changes the investig the uh investigator
position Swann officers and makes them
examiners as you know sworn officers are
are police officers they go to the
academy like the state police do and
they get uh and they they get an auto
mobile they got a a car uh very
expensive and in talking to the uh Mark
aagan he suggested that maybe we just he
just really needs two examiners
basically back room people doing the
examination so that's what this
amendment also does so those are the
three thing that the amendment
does um so I I would very much
appreciate that someone in the committee
move this amendment um Mr chair uh if
you feel more comfortable that we handle
this in ways the means I certainly would
do that in ways the means as well uh but
that's given your
call so Mr chair um I suggest you hear
from uh Chief amanian and Aiden
Moore uh next and they can give you more
specifics but I'm certainly willing to
answer any questions you may have thank
you representative Ry does anyone have
any questions for representative Bary I
do okay I recognize representative
lakus okay thank you uh Mr chair um I'm
seeing two amendments uh 2021 D 0116 H
and uh 0180 h on this bill I mean is one
replacing the other are both being
proposed I can explain that uh the chair
chair Maguire reached out to me to let
her know that she also has a an
amendment uh it's her position that uh
she doesn't want any of the additional
position positions her Amendment deletes
the
positions I see that thank you okay my
amendment is 0116
H okay thank you thank
you uh chair Roy I had I have a question
go ahead and representative Gord you
representative abami how many um how
many
uh
investigators are there currently
i u I'll be just guessing I know it's I
think it's around 15 or so but uh Chief
amanian is is I'm sure on it'll be
testifying next and he can give you the
exact answer on that thank you I'll wait
then thank you okay thank
you any further questions for
representative
abami
right
I'm just pausing for a minute for a
technical
adjustment
while we're doing technical thing when
uh people speak to question um centers
would you please ask them to identify
themselves because it's difficult to
know who
speak thank
you
okay okay at this point I'm going to
recognize Mark armag and chief of
enforcement uh you are recognized to
speak Chief you just have to unmute
yourself
um stand
by can someone speak to see if I we have
sound
here I canes can you speak please just
to test our sound yes I I'm speaking
okay so no
sound you hear it Mr chairman can you
hear me it's Mark armag okay we can hear
you now sorry we had a little technical
difficulty we're good to go you may
proceed if you could identify yourself
and thank you very much sir uh first of
all good morning uh my name is Mark
armaganian I am the chief of the new uh
Hampshire Liquor commission's Division
of enforcement
licensing um first and foremost we are
very grateful uh at The Liquor
Commission
uh that representative abrami uh brought
this bill forward it was brought forward
last year and got caught up and
everything and uh again this year now um
with that in mind um there there have
been over the years and I've been in
this position after leaving the state
police for 28 years uh for the last four
years uh it was very obvious to me when
I came into to this position that um
there were a lot of uh bills that were
brought forward over the years that
turned into law that created a lot of
interweaving between laws and and
created confusion uh like representative
abami brought up earlier uh when you
start identifying certain statutes in
title 13 um this is the first attempt to
clean things up um um and there will be
more attempts um in in the very near
future uh but uh as it as it pertains to
these positions um recognizing the
fiscal time that we're in right now um I
could tell you that uh and not to float
my own boat here for a lack of a better
term but um I I've over these last 34
years in law enforcement been very very
frugal um with the budgetary money that
has been graciously um earmarked for us
uh in both positions uh and um it was uh
through the benevolence of of the
committee uh ways and means when we were
in front of them that it was brought up
to us that there was a necessity for
these two
positions um to be brought forward uh a
as we have moved into these current
times um we all have to get a little bit
more creative um and one of the ways
that uh through the work of of myself
our legal coordinator Aiden Moore who is
one of my
predecessors uh and representative of
brownie um came up with this U
alternative
resolution uh and that would be uh to
use civilian uh examiners which are
actually for lack of a better term
they're
Auditors uh to keep an eye on the books
um and and uh the taxes that need to be
paid by this uh license type um and and
it's a substantially
less
um footprint Financial footprint than
the uh sworn investigators that were
originally uh earmarked for this
bill um with that in mind
uh representative abrami was correct uh
192 of these uh retailers are in the
tobacco only category and then we look
at our off premise which is our
groceries and convenience store and
there's hovering around
14450 and I say hovering because these
license types are are moving targets uh
on a daily
basis um we I Ironically in the world of
we have seen the uh vape shops not uh
not be as successful as they were hoping
um our overall
applications uh are up
667 uh from the time of uh Inception of
the shutdown uh back in
March uh and and let use St Patrick's
Day uh to the current date uh we're
actually up in
licensees um which which is a credit to
our investigators and the
partnership uh with our lenses we've
taken a uh a different role of years
gone past and that different role is uh
with this partnership we find uh success
in not only um not only our
collaborative uh movement but our
uh our way that we
uh find that each one of these lenses is
actually policing themselves into
compliance um that starts with a
Education
Foundation uh and we have a a really
robust Education Foundation here um it
moves up to uh
violations uh if they're warranted uh
but uh I will tell you that uh this
group along with uh the alcohol side of
our house um are are being very Vigilant
themselves and in and keeping compliance
so we felt that uh with this in mind our
our first step would be uh to alter
these positions into examiner or uh like
I said earlier it's easier to keep it
keep track of it as calling it an
auditor
position
um I uh as far as the rest of the bill
is concerned I'd like to bring on Aiden
Moore uh my colleague uh who who
actually um can speak better about some
of the movement within uh within this
amendment uh and within the original uh
Bill if if that's okay Mr
chairman okay uh first I see
representative O'Brien has a question
you recognize representative Brien
thank you Mr chairman and thank you sir
for taking my question on these new
particular positions um I just want to
know if the regular liquor enforcement
officer is under any type of contractual
agreement or you know under the uh
protection or coverance of a a union and
with these two new positions greatly
changed the Dynamic of what that basic
Collective collective bargaining
agreement May entail and therefore may
lead ourselves into a down the road of a
an argument of uh a situation where
perhaps maybe they wouldn't object if
these were full-time positions I just
wonder if you could elaborate on that
please thank you I Canen representative
thank you very much for your question
and uh and thank you for bringing that
up uh to say right now that we have uh
Union Harmony uh in this uh division is
an
understatement uh both civilian and
sworn here work uh collaborative
collaboratively in
harmony uh with with no hurdles or or
headaches um our civilians are covered
uh or our members if they so wish to be
part of the uh state employees union um
our sworn members are part of the
nepba um we actually have three unions
within us our uh commissioned officers
uh bar myself and the deputy chief are
part of a separate separate bargaining
uh entity within the nepba and that just
recently happened within the last month
um I will tell you that uh this
um along with a lot of other moves that
are that happen that might uh create
some hurdles between the unions have
have been talked about and uh this
endeavor uh switching these from
uh inspectors or
investigators uh sworn investigators
to um the the auditor positions or the
examiner positions uh was done with uh
no hesitation and no push back from
either Union president um we we actually
brought them into the room as part of
this
discussion uh thank you followup if I
may Mr chairman followup uh are they um
are the representative unions are they
going to speak in in support of
this uh they we did not set that up um
or did they offer they uh there was
trust that we would pass that
along
um my the quick answer to that is uh
they I don't see them out there and
there was no discussion of them
talking
ory getting at it uh thank you sir for
taking my question thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative uh
representative Shu you recognize for a
question yes thank you Mr chair um good
morning Mr armaganian um while I
appreciate the reality I have a couple
questions number one are there any
current officers or I don't know if this
the right word employees working in this
position uh as auditor
in your
department thank you representative uh
we have uh at this time three people um
that are working within the our auditing
Department that are working in the
positions of examiner or what I'm going
to call for our purposes so we don't
create confusion I hope I'm not creating
Confusion by saying this
Auditors um those uh current Curr those
uh three positions are actively uh
auditing approximately 2,000 of our Li
out of our 5600
lenses um most of it is behind the
scenes
um paperwork that is being done um there
is a hurdle switching this to an auditor
and that hurdle is if there is criminal
criminal
liability uh which is the the reason why
back in the day
um it was it it came to fruition that uh
the sworn um
investigators uh had law enforcement
Authority um it it would actually create
a circumstance that we would have to
bring a
sworn um investigator into the audit of
the particular ly if we had any criminal
culpability during that
audit um followup Mr chair
followup thank you um yeah that leads to
my next question um I have a known quite
a few of your former investigators or
officers I should say actually um
unfortunately they've all retired now
but I'm curious if um the difference
between
enforcement and the immediacy of
enforcement of an auditor as opposed to
an actual uh enforcement
officer thank you again representative
uh there is an immediacy that very good
um I I I appreciate your background in
in our division um there is a issue of
immediacy um um when it comes to taking
that type of action um that is something
that um is I I don't want to say an
unintended
consequence uh it is a consequence of
and something that that we debated um
and it wasn't an animated debate but we
went back and forth on on these
positions and and how
how they could actually
um take this
action um if it did go criminal um it it
would take some time getting an
investigator a sworn investigator a
police officer to to the location
depending on where they are um there
could be evidence that is lost um we
always are are concerned with the um
with the exigency of of handling a case
uh immediately due to the loss of of
credible evidence um these these
Auditors would be able to take
administrative action um which um that
was the
alternative um but again there's no
alternative
to uh a uh you know a criminal entity
um and and I I like to say that 99.9 of
our our lenses are doing it uh extremely
well and I I believe that in my heart
but I know that uh with within that and
within my 33 years of law
enforcement um I somebody's going to
trip along the way and and they're
whether it's they're going to trip
because they they over served or or they
ered something or they sold a product
that in this state is
illegal um and that caused the compound
issue whether it's a fatality on the
roadways or um we have had um
altercations that have happened at some
of our licens
establishments um that criminal action
has had to be taken um it that does
create a void it 100% it creates a void
it's a very good point
thank you very much for your honest
answer thank
you representative
goaly thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh just to
follow up uh knowing how many Auditors
you have how many uh investigators do
you have currently thank you
representative uh investigators right
now like I said uh there we have
approximately uh as of Friday I don't
have the numbers this morning uh
5661 active
lenes uh we have approximately 15
investigators that are in the field that
that's minus our part-time staff and um
our supervisory staff total we have
26 um that are sworn that are within
this division um and and our ratios are
somewhere in the area of
377 380 lenses per
[Music]
investigator thank you followup Mr
chairman follow
up this next question I guess would go
towards the original bill was adding two
investigators and the amendment came in
for um to examine our positions just to
save on costs could you really use the
investigators versus the
examiners I if I thank you again
representative uh it did put a that
wasn't something I brought forward uh in
the Inception of this bill um that was
something that uh the committee brought
to me um it put a smile on my face uh
because our people uh like most state
employees do more with less um and and
leaving uh when I left the other job
over at State Police and came over here
I I I I was truly humbled and and
blessed with the the work ethic that
goes on here um could those yes they
could um and and we could use those
those positions as sworn um I couldn't
give you a barometer on if
if a audit went uh
criminal the downtime that was put in in
the amount of money uh that would be
spent on that void I don't have a
barometer on that but I know that um
just downtime and switching roles and it
it's it's going to cost something I
don't know if it costs the
difference um I'm hoping not
thank you and just one more followup if
I may Mr chair follow
up uh looking at the funding for the
positions it says shall be funded when
determined that the fund has received
sufficient additional
Revenue now can you explain to me is
once the position's in is the position
in and if you Revenue goes down for a
year or so you don't lose those
positions or can you explain how that
wording affects those
positions um it was my understanding uh
thank you again representative it was my
understanding that once those ear marks
were met the position was in place as a
as a permanent position um uh I don't I
I didn't think about that being a a
position in
Jeopardy
um I guess the way I read it not I guess
the way I read it was that that position
was in in place and it was just to get
those were the a marks that were set
just to get that position into
place thank you thank you uh
representative
fellows thank you Mr chair um Mr
um AR
armagan um I'm interested in the
revenues that'll come in from these new
fees so you told us about the number of
um off premises in in the tobac only
places can can you tell me how many um
places on on premises liquor license
licenses also are paying this $6 fee for
the
tobacco go ahead yeah and and did um
I'll answer that I'll if you answer that
I'll follow up on the other
questions thank you thank you
representative um right now all uh all
inclusive I don't have the breakdown
individually um on premise uh we're
looking at uh just under
2,000 um
lies um off premise like I said earlier
it's uh right now it's
1,450 and then you have the 192 as the
Standalone ret s tobacco um of that um
the division brings in for license fees
just under uh $4
million
um3 Milli
9916 the way I have it written out in
front of me right now um I'd like to
verify those numbers and and if I could
get back to you on that just to make
sure that I'm giving you the most up
to-date
numbers um and I could do that before
the end of the day today actually before
launch so
um
followup
followup thank you so the other part of
my question was um are these the fees
that you that are in this bill are those
um it says license fees are those annual
or is it a one time with a renewal and
um also did the
agency give any consideration to
suggesting higher tobacco fees for those
on on premises
places sorry about that I got a little
feedback here
um so uh
the second part of your
question um was there consideration to
that I think it was very
um there was very quick consideration
given to that a reason being a couple
years back I say a couple years probably
further it was not during my term uh
with with the previous Chief um that was
attempted and and it it fell pretty
quickly
um the industry had
concerns um uh there were a lot of uh
Representatives that we went in front of
at the time that had great concerns over
it um and at that point it it it didn't
go anywhere so we we decided not to even
attempt to goow
down
thank
you are these annual fees or yes oh I'm
sorry I'm I'm sorry representative yes
they are annual
fees there are no other questions sir I
I have one question for
you
the it wasn't clear from the bill
whether these were tobacco or liquor
investigators and the reason I deleted
the positions with that amendment is
that my connections in the hospitality
industry think there are too many liquor
investigators at the moment do you have
any response to that I I do
representative thank you very much for
your your comment um I we just twofold
uh first of all um the information I
have uh on the lad that you said from uh
from our
licensees uh it conversely is the
opposite um and and that's even in our
uh Google surveys that we do uh on a
daily basis um management and ownership
when they're not in their
establishments want want to know that
their business is being done right and
want that
um want to be good in their heart that
that um they're they're not their
businesses aren't being run in a fashion
that would create liability from for
themselves um since I've come in um the
only thing I have heard from our lenses
is that um we that they want us to have
more people not less um and and uh this
is actually the first time I've heard uh
heard this in four years that uh they
want us to have less
investigators um I I will tell you and I
will put you in contact with with the
people um it's the direct opposite um
they want to have that confidence when
they're not there that their
establishments are being run right and
that we are spot checking them on a
nightly basis
thank you are there other
questions seeing
none EXC Mees representative Pearson
please and I'll try to use this area mic
can you can you hear me Sir Mark yes I
can thank you okay so you mentioned a a
ratio of 380 to one am I am I
understanding that correctly as far uh
the the last numbers I have of of course
uh please understand that this number
these lenses numbers move daily I get it
um the last number I have is actually 33
uh
3774 to one cl enough yep all right how
does that compare to
um even the New England region as far as
some of the other states go what do they
typically see averages between uh lenes
and your your office in that ratio range
or or is it something else no it it very
typical sir thank you very much for that
question uh and that's nationally uh not
just in New England um there are several
uh states that actually are set up
identical and and some are even more
robust than us um the Washington State
um has I think in the area the last I
checked ad investigators sworn
investigators um so it we're for this
region we're we're very similar to uh uh
colie and good friend of mine uh uh
Chief Skyler uh uh janess over in
Vermont uh we run very similar to them
uh extremely
similar thank you thank you other
questions seeing none
I call Katherine
Frey
next all right not
seeing miss fry if you're with us if
you'd raise your hand so we can let you
speak okay no AC in that case U Aiden
Moore I'm I'm sorry Kate fry is at the
top of the list because she raised her
hand okay there she is thank
you I have the ability to do it please
do it okay
Excuse Me Miss smling would you send
representative scitec the link as well
when you get a moment thank you she's up
she's
up the the link to
what the the link to the
meeting you got one this
morning hour he's having trouble okay
okay I can you hear me yes thank you
okay yes uh I think I was um tossed off
for a minute there uh good good morning
members of the committee my name is Kate
fry I'm um the vice president of
advocacy at new Futures we're
nonpartisan nonprofit organization that
Advocates educates and collabor uh
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all New Hampshire residents
we've been working for years on
substance misuse prevention policies and
um particularly arounds one that deter
substance misuse among Youth and Young
adults so the um uh vaping epidemic is
some people uh refer to it it was on our
radar for many years and we've been
working very closely with um the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission other
partners and um New Hampshire Ways and
Means on different bills around this um
so I will be very brief and just say we
are supportive of HB 591 there was a lot
of work that went into it with the ways
and means committee we are very
supportive of the Liquor Commission
having the resources that they need to
support um it's the new somewhat new
responsibilities they have around um
tobacco and vaping and um the
enforcement at age 21 so I would ask the
committee to pass this bill and pass it
on to Ways and Means where they have had
a lot of experience with um looking at
the revenue of this bill and the need um
and that's really all I have to say and
we ask the committee to support this and
thank you for your
time thank you
questions all right seeing none Aiden
Moore Good Day committee members Madam
chair my name is Aiden Moore I'm the
legal coordinator for the State Liquor
Commission are you able to hear me all
right yes thank you
um I have been working with
representative abrami and I guess I have
a question um we have the original Bill
591 and I believe this morning he
introduced Amendment
21-
0116 so I'm not
sure uh what of which of these uh bills
uh you would like me to address or that
you would like me to speak
to um I know afraid excuse me sir you'll
have to address both of them since not
all of the committee has actually
received that Amendment yet okay thank
you very much ma'am
uh the original bill I think was as
representative abrami mentioned brought
when um his committee last year uh
looked at the whole issue of vape shops
there was quite a bit of legislation
that came through around ecigarettes
and The Lure of those businesses that um
were um selling uh Vape products and who
were at that point in time
unregulated the bill that came initially
591 in our review of this bill uh
proposes two things it would repeal the
$6 fee that tobacco licenses pay
currently and replace it uh on your bill
lines 7 through 13 with a fee
schedule which essentially
mirrors
the uh pricing for what is referred to
as combination lies that are businesses
that hold a license to sell alcohol wine
and beer under RSA
17818 under
591 if the $6 fee were
replaced with this fee schedule and I'll
use an example just to illustrate what
the impact would
be a convenient store that has a single
register uh and has a license to sell
alcohol would pay
$336 under 591 If This Were to
pass they would no longer pay the
additional
$6 for the tobacco license they would
pay an additional
$336 for a tobacco
license so they would essentially would
pay 336 for their alcohol license and
add IAL 336 for a tobacco
license I don't believe excuse me I
don't believe that was the intent um of
the uh bill when it was initially
introduced but the way
591 was written that is the way it would
be interpreted and applied if it became
law with that information we sat down
and and also excuse me before I proceed
to the amendment uh 591 also has the two
investigator positions in it and has as
its required uh
Milestones the the requirement that the
um establishment of the two positions is
linked to revenue that is brought in as
a result of this fee
change if you were to look at the uh
bill as it's written where by my example
a business would pay
$336 for a alcohol license and an
additional
$336 for their tobacco license and
that's also a business that has just one
register you can see in in the initial
bill that there is a a scale that
increases the cost of the licenses uh
based upon the number of registers the
legislative policy I believe was to say
the bigger the business the more
registers you have the more you're able
to sell alcohol Therefore your fee
should
increase so if the if you looked at
591 um it's very possible that those
Milestones could be achieved because the
revenue that would be coming in would be
significantly greater than what exists
currently um it seems unlikely that
there may be an interest in
increasing um those tobacco
fees uh for a business that holds a
license to sell alcohol already to this
new level and therefore um we worked
with representative abrami to bring
about what we believe was the probably
the intended
consequence to leave the increases the
the new fee schedule for those
businesses that do not hold a license to
sell
alcohol and if um Madame chair if it's
possible could I directly um I know
everybody does not have the amendment so
I guess my question was how would you
like me to address what is included in
the amendment and how it is
distinguished from the original
591 do your best I so if I do I
understand you correctly to say that
instead of Simply doubling the alcohol
fee the amendment gives you gradated
tobacco fees for tobacco only
businesses yes ma'am the you will you
would see in the amendment uh that
representative abrami was bringing that
we have now included language that would
say uh to the business that holds an
alcohol license I'll use the same
example the convenience store that has a
license to sell beer and wine for
$336 under lines
11-13 of the amendment any business that
holds a license to sell alcohol would
continue to pay only $6 for their
license so the unintended consequence of
591 would be
dampened and the only businesses that
would be paying the adjusted fee would
be those businesses that are tobacco
only and in this you'll see that 591 for
example has has a single registered fee
of
$336 under representative of rami's
amendment that would drop to
$216 and the rationale behind that is a
combination beer and wine license is
essentially paying a license for a
license to sell two products so if they
were not going to sell two products we
do have a model in a license type that
we offer called a wine retailer where a
wine retail license would only pay would
pay a reduced amount because they're
only selling one product so we felt that
that was a fair
comparison and a fair approach and
therefore in the amendment on lines
three through six you'll see a fee
schedule different from 591 lower but it
represents that fee schedule which
exists currently for a wine retailer
license now of course that fee
adjustment in that I spoke about leaving
the retailers with a $6 fee if they hold
an alcohol
license and only looking at Revenue
new Revenue coming from the retail
tobacco only
business I it would it would be almost
impossible for the division to reach its
Milestones to establish investigator
positions as as Chief armaganian stated
as representative abramy stated these
are very expensive
positions um I think in past last year
we provided his committee with fiscal
worksheet IND those positions were going
to be approximately
134,000 each um as opposed to what would
be the cost to establish a civilian
examiner position and the fact that um
these positions are really uh often
focused on
ensuring compliance and Revenue
collection and that therefore the more
there are the more positions there are
to ensure the revenue is coming in uh
the greater likelihood that nothing
slips through the cracks and that all
the revenue that the state is due is
collected um I believe Chief armaganian
has um looked at some costs associated
with examiner positions
versus uh investigator
positions and so I would defer certainly
to him if you have additional questions
on that those
costs but I hope I've done a a credible
job of trying to distinguish the
challenges of
591 and what we believe the Cure would
be that would come through with
representative Abram's
Amendment take any
questions okay I see representative
abramy to speak is there anyone else
with questions so sorry representative
fellows um yes I thank you madam chair I
just wondered it would be a lot easier
to understand if we had a little handout
that with examples of the different
kinds of um establishments and what they
pay reprentative fellows you're
absolutely
correct we that is however the province
of ways and means we are to to look at
the general policy rather than the
details of the fees and the
revenue they this bill will be going to
Ways and Means after if we if we pass it
so they will be examining the details of
the fees so um Madam chair I was
interested my perspective was the impact
on those local businesses that's why I
was interested in seeing that
yes thank you I understand and I
appreciate
uh Mr mois examples that showed that the
original bill was going to double their
fees whereas the
amendment makes no change to to existing
um
agencies so I think that in that POS
alone we have to support the amendment
in order to deal with the uh with our
local
businesses
okay I'm I'm
still we've got the original bill and
the Amendments and so I'm just not clear
what happens what the fees turn out to
be under the different
scenarios fine we will dis discuss this
further in executive session if you
don't
mindes representative of
raming yes thank you madam chair for
allowing me to speak a second time uh
repr fellows uh go to section go to RSA
17829 Roman 2 and you will see the fee
schedules currently actually it's it's
actually if you look at the whole
section there's three pages of fees that
are all over the place so it's an
interesting view um Madame chair I just
wanted to comment about the um the
trigger in the bill uh came from
Finance uh and I can't exactly remember
the sequence of events last term but uh
we we did our work and then uh the when
it came to the new positions our bill
was not scheduled the bill was not
scheduled to go to finance so we called
finance and and they gave us that
language about the triggers just so you
know actually when it comes to these
positions
technically Edna or waying means this is
really a this is really a finance
question if you want to be technical
about it so um and I think uh again
there's really only one thing in this
bill that has to do with Edna and that's
is there a retail tobacco
license and and everything else in this
bill is either a Ways and Means question
as the chair has mentioned or a finance
question um and there is thank you
representative AB brami I was wondering
why this bill showed up in this
Committee in the first place I I agree
and I I talked I
[Music]
talked the bill that the person with the
dog please mute
themselves go on representative of Ramy
yes technically this is a way it means
Bell I'm fact we were surprised when we
saw an Edna and I I know represented
major contacted you and you said well we
we got the bill so we're going to deal
with it so so um hopefully uh you'll
you'll pass one version of this um if
you want to deal with Madam chair if you
want to deal with my Amendment uh that'd
be fine uh if not I can deal with it
when hopefully you passed the bill so we
can uh correct this again in in the
intent the reason for the the major
reason for the amendment is that we
really wanted to tighten the language up
after we relooked at it uh I was
contacted by Aiden and uh uh Moore and
and Chief amanian and I I worked with
them for the last month on going through
it and coming up with this amendment to
make sure that that the the current
licenses with liquor licenses aren't
going to be double charged for uh having
the tobacco license we're now convinced
that now the language is correct so
that's what this Amendment does for the
most part thank you we will be studying
that Amendment prior to executing this
bill because clearly it's a a an
improvement over the original yes thank
you and I I did forward that Amendment
through what I thought was the proper
way which was through the uh testimony
thing that they
created um and I know you got it because
you you you email me that you had
received it so thank
you uh okay I will have to speak speak
with our assistant on why the rest of us
didn't is there anyone else who wishes
excuse
me yeah no it it me it says to the
committee it goes it says to the
committee on the uh when you when you
click on I understand it's the error is
probably on our side no know who knows
is is Nancy Von with
us
yes please speak Miss vaugh yes good
morning um I'm H Nancy vaugh uh
government relations director for the
American Heart Association and um I just
wanted to comment that um as we were
last year we are in support of um this
bill um and uh in the continuing good
work of the um the Liquor Commission and
helping to enforce um tobacco sales laws
um and I just wanted to I did submit
written testimony um um and I really
just wanted to um point out one
paragraph of my testimony I don't know
if this is the appropriate committee um
for this but um I think it is uh
definitely something I would um like to
to start a conversation on um the
American Heart Association um across the
country actually is working in different
states on Tobacco um retailer licensing
bills that also um remove um state law
that is currently on the books that
allow pen penties on youth for the
purchase use and possession of tobacco
um we support the repeal of these which
New Hampshire does have a law for this
um because they are ineffective at
deterring youth initiation of tobacco
and um and often are in equitably
implemented um against youth from
lowincome communities as well as youth
of color um and you know basically
tobacco companies Market their products
purposefully um to these population
groups um and these thank you miss vau
this is that's fascinating but it has
very little to do with the bill in front
of us okay we are a bit over schedule
most definitely and I appreciate your um
accepting my testimony thank you very
much are there other questions from the
committee all right seeing
none close the public hearing on House
Bill
591 and open hearing on House Bill
94 and Madam chair yes Mr representative
goalie just one quick question
um we uh that aren't in the room are not
seeing uh blue sheet signin could you
just let us know when we get done the
bills how many have signed in in favor
versus opposition yes thank you for the
reminder also Madam chair I I'm well it
was there a minute ago I was seeing
um Mr um if I can get his name right uh
the enforcement officer had his hand
raised until just a moment yes I saw
that and I think we've heard quite
enough from him
today thank you he spoken he's responded
to an exhaustive list of questions and I
think the that uh we've closed the
hearing thank
[Music]
you
okay I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
94 and I'm going to call Representative
Maguire who's the lead sponsor of that
bill I'm gonna have to get you a mic
from one of the
tables
thank you Mr chair now that I've
established trip
hazards uh I'm Carol McGuire
representing marac District
29 which is the towns of Allenstown
Epsom and
Pittsfield I'm the sponsor of House Bill
94 which was a request by the off
professional licensure and
certification what it does
is re it establishes that all of the
licenses are twoe rather than
one
and
um and they
expire on one's birthday ra the month
month's
birthday um
rather than at a specific date some of
the boards were all expiring in May or
January whatever and that's much less
efficient this is a and it establishes
that the board the director of oplc has
the authority to set the micro the feeds
the license fees rather than the
boards they still have their technical
Authority discipline and so forth they
do not have the fee
issu essentially this bill cleans up
some old language and is an efficiency
Improvement for the oplc it has
no technical changes whatsoever There's
issues on how they will
um how they will phase out the the old
licenses and renew them they're they're
um they have partial fees for partial
years that they will be renewing and
that's it you have if you have any
technical any questions I'll try to
answer
them right does any member of the
committee have a question for
representative
McGuire being No Hands the chair is
going to call Tina Kelly from oplc and I
will unmute you in a
second Miss Kelly you should be able to
speak good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Tina Kelly
and I am here representing the office of
professional licensure and certification
oplc this bill is designed as
representative Maguire stated to
standardized renewals and we're doing
those in small groups the first group is
the 12 that are listed there to ensure
ease of transition from um a standard
month of renewal to having them renew
across the year and the renewal would be
done two years from the date of initial
lure and in doing that we're going to
ensure that all boards or all licenses
who get license will get a complete
two-year license there will be no need
to prate fees and no need to prate
continuing education it should make it
easier for the Len he to understand and
to comply with and it'll also make it
easier for oplc to administer spreading
out the renewals across the year and not
Jewish doing them in all in June or all
in November so it it should make um for
both lenses and oplc life much
easier um the transition is the only
time there is pro rating and that is to
ensure that the um lensey being switched
from their set time of renewal to the
two-year from initial licensure they
would get a um license for two years
plus however months however many months
and that way um they they're insured
those two
years um I think that pretty much covers
it and I'm here to take any
questions thank you very much Miss Kelly
do we have any questions from the
committee
um I do have a question thises yes
representative gr thank you um Miss
Kelly could you please explain the
benefit of having the director set the
fees versus the Board
uh good question that has already
actually been set in another statute
where the um director of oplc has the
authority or to set those
fees um we're getting ready to clarify
that in another bill change because a
lot of the boards have it set right in
their statute so that'll be um clarified
in other statute but what it'll be able
to do is keep us within that 125% of
operating costs and ensure that um
they're that lenses are not paying more
than what they're um require they should
be
paying okay do I have any other
questions from the committee and I have
no questions currently from
attendees representative
goalie thank you Mr chairman um I'm
curious as to where the boards stand on
these changes that these are
affecting oh great question now before I
took my position my my new position with
oplc I was the administrator of the
Allied Health boards and those seven
boards um we had worked on very very
similar legislation to switch them
over um last year and as we all know
that a lot of things were tabled and
this was one of them so as far as those
seven boards go they are on board with
this I have not spoken directly to the
other boards but this will not take away
any Authority that they have it just
changes their time of
renewal so that it's um easier to
administer and a followup
absolutely uh I think uh one of the
statements you made is this is currently
being done and due to changes in other
statutes um just questioning how then
why is
this legislation needed if you're
currently doing it or how are you doing
it if this legislation hasn't
passed no that was only the fees so only
the fees which the director off oplc
has the authority to set is set in other
statute um it may be unclear in certain
places and that is what's being worked
on just that um clarification for the
authority of oplc to set the
fees thank
you okay do I have any other
questions seeing no questions from the
committee seeing no questions from
attendees I'm going to close up public
hearing on health Bill
for
he's got to
reopen and if you do you may not be a
panelist
sure start with it I'll open
har okay we're gonna go ahead and open
house bill
70 the chair calls representative
Maguire to introduce
the Bill thank you Mr chair the house
bill 70 is a repeat of a bill that
passed the house last year on consent
and this committee on consent and died
in the Senate due
to one thing or another it microblading
of eyebrows is a permanent makeup
technique that is considered tattooing
because it involves breaking into the
skin it is a very simple version of
tattooing and right now this cosmetic
procedure requires a complete tattoo
artist license which requires a minimum
of onee
apprentice some people want
to to do this with less than
that and so I worked at a constituent
request and I worked with the T the body
art board to discover how to do
that they decided that the a licensed
cosmetologist or an
esthetician has a lot of the
basic annotation in dealing with faces
and stuff like that so that they would
need only a
simplified
course they to safely perform
microblading so this language is what
that board gave to me last year
and it authorizes a
certificate which is an addendum to the
aestheticians or cosmetologist license
that this person has attended the class
and passed the test and uh meets the
that meets the the board of body Arts
requirements for sanitation and and
proper proper performance of this
technique Bill gives them the rules
to
uh apply the forms performance standards
in work and
disciplinary
requirements there is no additional
effort required on the part of the Board
of Cosmetology
they have their their regular ones
and that's all I I have to say if you
have questions I'll try and
answer does any member of the uh
committee have a question for
representative
Maguire I seeing no questions from the I
have a question from an attendee uh Ryan
olette and I will bring you up so you
can
speak Mr olette hello can you hear me
yes uh good morning uh I'd like to start
by thanking the committee for this time
to speak on issues related to public
health and safety in our state my name
is Ryan wette I have been a licensed
body art practitioner and business owner
in New Hampshire for over 20 years in
addition to running my business I am
also a member of the state's body art
Advisory Board which supports the office
of professional lure and certification
the oplc with supervision of tattooing
and bodypiercing services here in New
Hampshire in July of 2019 I was tasked
with writing and delivering a
presentation about the risks of
microblading for state legislators and
members of the
oplc since microblading is a relatively
newer service it has not yet clearly
been defined by the state of New
Hampshire we are understanding of those
outside of the body art industry looking
to offer a potentially lucrative service
such as microblading but through the
lens of what we do as licensed body art
practitioners the service commonly
referred to as microblading is very
clearly cosmetic tattooing presenting
microblading as a service Under the
Umbrella of Cosmetology or other
professions that do not primarily work
with broken skin or blood May
misrepresent or underscore some of the
risks
involved in body art terms microblading
clearly falls under the definition of
tattooing which in New Hampshire is any
indelible Mark made upon the skin
through use of pigment or Scar Tissue
the term microblading refer refers to a
service where the skin is broken by a
device with a sharp edge and pigment is
inserted the sharp Implement is very
fine and can replicate the look of a
sculpted eyebrow hair uh I feel the need
to clarify that this procedure does in
fact break the skin which can produce
bleeding and all the safety concerns
caused by a bleeding wound while I
understand and respect the investment of
time training undergone by those in the
cosmetology and esthetician Fields
including their General hygiene
practices I do have concerns that their
existing training does not sufficiently
prepare them to perform Services
involving broken skin and bleeding on a
daily basis hp70 lays out a type of
certification exemption for
cosmetologist to add microblading to
their services unfortunately that
certification is the make or break
factor of this issue without a clear
standard of acceptable certification in
New Hampshire Our concern is that much
of the available training for
microblading falls into the weekend
seminar or expedited learning category
and service providers may not receive a
sufficient level of training to protect
the public health for contrast those in
the New Hampshire body art industry have
undergone a minimum one-year
apprenticeship to offer services that
involve broken skin while a
certification may offer sufficient
training to offer microblading without
knowing the standards of that
certification the body art advisory
panel cannot support this bill as it is
written so my current uh position is to
oppose hb70 this statute would in a way
deregulate cosmetic tattooing by
allowing it to be performed by those
outside of New Hampshire lure and
supervision for body art we understand
those looking to offer a service in
demand however my first concern must be
to protect public health and safety in
New Hampshire the body Ard Advisory
Board continues to research microblading
and its available training and will
continue to advise the oplc on this
matter for input or questions related to
microblading practitioners in either
cosmetology or body artart can contact
the office of professional Li insurance
and certification through oplc nh.gov I
thank you for your time and
consideration on this
matter thank you Mr wette does anyone
have any questions from Mr
wette I've had raised my hand I see you
go ahead
represent thank you Mr chairman uh Mr
well Willet I'm deeply grateful for your
appearance before us today because uh
although I don't profess to have any
expertise um in this particular skill
this particular art uh I am deeply
concerned about uh the amount of
training that would be necessary to
perform this uh not only effectively but
safely uh and as a member of this
committee for uh now 15 years I have
seen examples of uh members of the
public who have been harmed by inexpert
uh treatment of some aspect of their
face um and I'm I'm very concerned so
your testimony is very uh insightful to
me with regard to the amount of training
that would be required for someone who
is even as as much skill and training as
in involved in cosmetology and
aesthetician uh Services uh the extra
aspect of breaking the skin um and and
involving blood uh is of considerable
concern to me so can you expand on the
amount of additional training in terms
of time and coursework that you believe
would be required uh in order for
someone with a CO cosmet ology or
esthetician basis to be sufficiently
skilled in the additional aspects you
reference and I'm referencing in my
question in order to do this safely but
also effectively because this is not
just uh a tattoo on an arm a back or
whatever but it's on very close to the
eye and it would be extremely visible uh
and it disfigurement is something that
I'm also very concerned about I I think
with your background as a tattoo artist
uh that you're uniquely qualified to
speak to this issue so could you please
help us with this uh yes sir uh
unfortunately it's it's kind of a
state-to-state issue by what
certification means uh there are some
states that that might not be very
engaged in the process at all they might
allow someone to take uh a simple
weekend seminar and then start offering
these Services immediately uh other
states might have certification that
falls into the uh weeks if not months of
training x amount of hours 100 hours 500
hours it it it varies quite a bit state
byst state they don't have um Universal
training certifications uh for the the
entire nation so what I would prefer to
see in New Hampshire is for us to Define
um minimum training certification
requirements uh because I I also
wouldn't feel comfortable with someone
being able to offer a service where they
B basically cut and aaid the the face
with only a weekends of training so
while I I fully respect the the work
that cosmetologists and and
aestheticians do to um to pursue their
Craft um it does take some specialty
training to understand well how do you
make sure that that wound heals without
an infection how do you make sure that
you're fully disinfecting your your work
surfaces and and your equipment for the
the next client uh and without having a
clear definition of what that training
is for New Hampshire uh it it's not
something that I can I can support at
this time our advisory panel our
Advisory board for body art um has been
researching training available in other
states and it's a a very confusing issue
because some states are completely
unregulated some states are heavily
regulated some states fall in the middle
um we can start to pull
information uh but then we have to say
well what what training facilities are
going to be available to someone
operating in New Hampshire if there are
no current microblading schools in New
Hampshire what are we expecting people
to do to go down to maybe another state
where they can knock this out in a few
hours or to go to a state where they
would have to commute and and do several
weeks if not months of of
training uh due to covid uh that can
also potentially limit available
training because procedures that involve
broken skin on someone's face would
typically require in-person training
that might not be available right now so
it's a it's a difficult and complicated
issue um if hb70 were to pass without
defining that certification it could
potentially create a moment where we um
are asking people to operate under the
honor System alone and while I do
respect people working in New Hampshire
um I I wouldn't necessarily feel that
that would make me comfortable as far as
uh the terms of public health and safety
follow up Mr chairman yes go ahead
thank you so am I correct that although
cosmetology and aesthetician Services uh
at first blush no pun intended uh seem
to be somewhat similar that are they not
fundamentally different uh crafts with
regard to what is involved in Breaking
the skin um and in in and in injecting
if you will some kind of
permanent um
pigmentation uh aspect into the eyebrow
are they not fundamentally
different uh yes sir I would believe
that they are fundamentally different
some of the specific questions related
to cosmetology might be better served to
someone on one of their uh advisory
bodies but as far as body art goes um if
we're performing a service that is is
going to cause bleeding um we have lots
of training our our entire studios are
designed to be able to man manage that
bleeding safely to prevent infections we
have entire sterilization rooms in our
Studios if we're not working fully
disposa we have a very specific setup
very specific criteria for for
disinfection training and that's all
that's all done through a a one-on-one
face-to-face apprenticeship process so
someone observes for x amount of hours
someone performs under supervision for x
amount of hours this isn't something
that's being done in an expedited
fashion so I I I would certainly uh urge
the the cosmetology uh governing bodies
and advisory panels to also get involved
in this conversation but as someone
whose background is is clearly rooted in
in body art um I I very firmly see
microblading as tattooing and then I
start to see all of the issues that
would arise offering a safe tattoo
service and I wouldn't feel comfortable
offering some of those services with
potentially just a weekend's worth of
training just one quick followup Mr qu
Mr chairman uh Mr wette would you be
available to uh to this committee uh for
future reference and guidance uh on this
very complex subject yes sir I'm always
happy to answer any questions for uh
anyone related to State legislation or
anyone related to the uh office of
professional liur and certification
thank you very much sir thank you
representative Shu
it thank you Mr chair uh good morning Mr
elette um for my core memory I know we
belt dealt with this bill in the 2020
session but my memory of uh our hearing
on it is rather dim uh did you or from
the body art Advisory Board testify on
that bill uh to my knowledge no one from
the body art advisory panel was was part
of that hearing there may have been
someone from the cosmetology board um we
do share one member on the body art
board with the the cosmetology board so
it's possible that they might have been
involved in one of those conversations
but I myself was not thank you thank
you any further questions from Mr wette
for Mr
wette there being none thank you Mr
wette for your testimony thank
you next I would like to recognize Laura
Smith Smith you've been promoted to
panelist please unmute and identify
yourself good morning sorry about that
that's all right go ahead um if it
please the committee I'd like to just
point out a few key points from my
written testimony um that Mr wette did
not point out in
opposition um to start I'm majority
owner of twist Hat 2 and I am a licensed
body art practitioner since 2008 I hold
licensing licensing I'm
sorry um in both tattooing and
bodypiercing and I currently specialize
in cosmetic and paramal Tech
toing um I have over 230 hours of
training in paramedical tattooing as
well as 3,000 hours in both my apprenti
from both my
apprenticeship um this Pro this proposed
bill has the potential to greatly
interfere with the livelihood of many
tattoo practitioners who are licensed to
microblade and already offer this Tech
technique as also and equally important
it also poses a certain threat to the
public as Mr L did bring
up um
microblading is a tattoo technique in
which tight a tight grouping of inline
needles are used to open the skin at the
level of the upper dermis to place
pigment the technique has Associated
risks that include but are not limited
to cutting too deep into the Derm RIS
which can cause not only severe scarring
but also blurring of the tattoo Line
work these two things combined can lead
to the disfigurement of a client's face
proper dep is depth is something that
tattoo practitioners are well trained in
knowing and and feeling however it can
take a long time to establish the fill
through proper tattoo apprenticeship and
a lot of Hands-On
training in an earlier language used by
the body art advisor Advisory board at a
meeting on 125 2019 I quote the board
generally agreed to permit an exemption
for estheticians to perform microblading
with a powered machine only this is
concerning as microblade is not
performed with a machine this is is an
example of how easy it is to mistake
microblading for other te 2
techniques sorry eyebrow tech tech 2
techniques microblading is performed
with a manual hand device
only in most US states cosmetologist and
estheticians are not allowed to affect
living tissue the
microblade the microblade tattoo
technique like all Tattoo Techniques
does directly affect living
tissue changing regulations for a single
tattoo technique will require
establishing new regulations for for
medical waste including Sharps
containment and Disposal bloodborne
pathogens training disinfection
sterilization sterilization and
recordkeeping for release and
Rel release and waiver
forms changing regulations for a single
tattoo technique will cause hardship for
tattoo practitioners who are already
safely providing quality microblading
tattoo services for their clients
changing regulations for a single tattoo
technique will cause hardship for
clients who won't be able to receive
finishing and touch-up procedures from
their chosen tattoo practitioner and
ultimately they would have be forced to
seek out less qualified individuals to
perform services for
them um in closing to protect the health
and safety oh I'm sorry I wanted to
mention one more thing on 1221 I began
an online petition and in only 11 days
we gathered 137 signatures this would
indicate the public shares Our concern
in closing to protect the health and
safety of the public and to prevent
certain hardship for affected licensed
tattoo
practitioners as well as their clients I
would like to reiterate that
microblading is just another name for
one Advanced technique of cosmetic
eyebrow tattooing and it should remain
regulated as tattooing it should remain
to be performed only by licensed tattoo
practitioners who have completed the
state required, 1500 hours of tattoo
training through a licensed body art
practitioner tattoo apprenticeship as
well as cosmetic tattooing and
microblade specific training and
certification thank you for hearing my
testimony uh thank you Miss Smith will
you take questions from the committee
please yes H representative
schmidth thank you Mr chairman and Miss
Smith thank you for being with us this
morning
um you where is your establishment
located in Nashville New Hampshire uh in
Nashville and would you also be
available to the committee or possibly
to a subcommittee uh to uh guide us with
regard to uh safely um you know
legislating in this field yes I
definitely would thank you very much
thank you uh representative
fellows thank you Mr chair I just have a
quick question so um the
sterilization and
Equipment um that would be required to
do this procedure already exists within
a tattoo parlor but you can you tell me
if these um the required equipment and
what that might be um are currently what
you would find in a beauty
salon um Sharps Containers would be one
item um in some cases an autoclave to
sanitize equipment although a lot of
equipment is um um single use and dispos
disposable at this time um
h i I apologize I wasn't prepared for
the question
um let me go back
um that's okay I mean you can if you
think of more you can send us an email
okay thank you I
apologize uh representative
goalie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question um and looking at the
uh there's a list under what's going to
be done for Ru making and one of those
uh is the standards of hygiene for
performing
microblading wouldn't that be
considered uh in Ru making which you're
discussing here into um Sharps
Containers and things such yeah yes
thank you thank
you any further
questions they being none thank you Miss
Smith for your
testimony the chair would next like to
recognize Kathy de jardan but I don't
see you I see a Cathy if that is you
please raise your
[Music]
hand it's
prob
M good morning can you hear me I can
thank thank you please identify yourself
for the record
and continue my my name is Kathy darten
I live in Manchester New
Hampshire okay thank you
proceeding good morning Mr chair and
honorable members of the
committee I appear before the committee
today in support of House Bill 70 as
some of you may remember I served on
this committee last session
as representative Maguire said at the
time this bill at that time the bill was
heard before the committee and was
reported out as ought to pass the house
passed the bill and the legislation was
sent to the Senate unfortunately the
bill got caught up in the covid epidemic
and ended up not being included in this
Senate omnus bill at the end of the
session I am
a beneficiary of
microblading after being diagnosed with
breast cancer followed by surgery and
radiation I lost my
eyebrows while that surgery and
radiation treatment were successful my
appearance was
concerning well I cannot deny there was
some vanity involved I can honestly tell
you that my decision to turn to
microblading was very much a part of my
therapeutic therapy
thery after this procedure I felt that I
was truly back to my old
self this procedure should be available
to members of the public at a reasonable
cost I truly
believe that this is not a tattoo and my
research has definitely proved that to
be true the procedure is much different
than a normal tattoo and I have to add
of which I have
had I urge the members of the committee
to support House Bill 70 and send it to
the house floor as ought to pass thank
you very
much thank you representative uh is
there any uh questions from the
committee there being none I thank you
very much thank
you and next I do not see on the list
but I see someone named hly Rodriguez
requesting to speak on the
attendees Mr chairman you may ask a
procedural question absolutely go ahead
thank you very much uh do we have
anybody among the attendees who who is a
currently practicing
microblader um other than Miss Smith uh
who was already testified but um I would
like to hear having especially having
heard from The Honorable Kathy Darden uh
with regard to the importance of having
microblading available to the citizens I
would like to hear from so from other
practitioners if they are here with
regard to the requirements so that we
can uh can move forward in a proper
manner uh thank you for the question
representative I don't know that there's
any way I could determine who among the
attendees was a practicing microblader
so we're just going to go forward with
the people that have signed up to speak
or raising their hand and perhaps we'll
get lucky that way um so I recognize
Holly Rodriguez if you un unmute your
microphone hi good morning my name is
Holly Rodriguez I'm I'm in the capacity
of um representing myself however I am
the board chair for the Board of
Cosmetology and
atics and um we did discuss this at our
board but we did not have time before
this meeting to have a proper board
meeting or have a um a a board Quorum so
we could discuss it so I am coming forth
to this um to your representatives um as
myself and I do I am in favor of this
bill however I do think I agree with um
Ryan wette that I think that there
should be some more than just a weekend
training I think that you have
esthetician and cosmetologist who are
very well suited and and can do some
credible um sanitation and disinfect um
that's what they do that's what they
learn at school that's what they they
have sharp containers if they use l sets
or anything like that they have those
things in their rooms now um I do
believe that the semi-permanent
tattooing that's done for sparse
eyebrows utilizing a hand tool not a
mechanical tool would be something with
the proper education that a
cosmetologist or ES could could do to um
be able to assist the public and have
other people able to perform this
procedure right now the only way for
someone to do that is to Apprentice with
a tattoo artist who primarily not all of
them are doing just eyebrow tattoos so
right now there's no there's nothing in
any law that says say I was going to go
and I wanted to Apprentice with a tattoo
artist to get this I could have I could
do my apprenticeship
with any tattoo artist doing regular
tattoos on people's arms and legs and
backs and chest but not on the face
whereas if we're able to make this
training appropriate you'd be able to
cater this so when people are getting
trained and getting apprenticed with
whatever we feel is the right thing it's
mandated to be right on what they're
going to be training on not apprenticing
with a tattoo artist who may be doing
backs arms legs and doing permanent you
more permanent Tattooing in a very
different very different way than if
someone's doing it on their eyebrows
which is a very cosmetic application so
I believe that um representative Smith
and um also with Ryan roulette I do
agree with what they're saying that
there should be some more than one
weekend I think that it definitely needs
to be you know maybe a a cboard
situation that we could come up with
what we felt a syllabus would be
appropriate for we've done that with
other things such as tanning uh tanning
and other things that we wanted to make
sure they had the appropriate training
um so I do think it's something that can
be done and I also believe that with
cosmetology and Aesthetics having their
license um based on sanitation and
sterilization that they would be an
appropriate person to work with this
cosmetic application with the
appropriate training so I am in favor of
the bill and I'm happy to answer any
questions if you have
it thank you uh representative
Fells thank you Mr chair um Miss Ro
rodri
do you think that um somebody who has
who's certified in
cosmetology would have a step up over a
per just any person taking the required
training absolutely because they already
have almost o over a year of schooling
on sanitation and sterilization they
already know that they do that they're
inspected by our state board which we
have two inspection inspectors that go
out and inspect these um these lies
these New Hampshire lenses just on their
sterilization and sanitation so if
there's still upstanding lenes in our
state they they have already that
background of Sanitation and
sterilization and keeping our Public
Safety at the utmost um
importance um representative
goalie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question as I look at the
legislation and I think this was all
discussed last year and
why uh most of us voted to move this
forward um the new paragraph is under
body art and rul making and the
paragraph says that the requirements to
obain and renew for microblading include
application forms and approval
microblading
courses so my question goes we're hear
about everybody throwing out there a
weekend course or a day course and that
hasn't been defined yet it's going to be
The Bodyguard folks from what I see here
who come forward with the rulle
making is that not the case or am I
missing
something it was my understanding uh rep
uh representative goalie that the um
because we do have one of those members
on our board as well as a P public
member and that they were
making the syllabus of what they felt
was appropriate once this was as an
ought to pass and what they thought was
an appropriate syllabus
for it to be followed by aesthetic and
Cosmetology licens in the state of New
Hampshire so that's why I we didn't have
a meeting um before because we thought
that that was already kind of figured
out so I'm coming on here representing
myself but I too had already thought
that that was the way it was going to be
that they were going to mandate what
they felt was the most important and
what needed to be followed in that
syllabus and it wasn't a timeline it was
more of what needed to be
followed thank you and just one followup
followup I agree and wouldn't you agree
that also the other requirement
standards of hygiene for performing
microblading uh writing rules on that
procedure too would be suffice to cover
what we're looking for here to make it
safe are you asking me representative
yes I
am yes absolutely I think that is
something that that these lenses already
have in their practice and just that's
something to for them to expound on and
and grow on and they already have that
as their base of their license as it is
if they're already an upstanding license
SE so it's something they're already
practicing thank
you you're welc thank you any further
questions for M Rodriguez uh
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Rodriguez
thank you very much for being with us
this morning um uh I respect your
position as a the chair of the
cosmetology board um and and
so I noticed that in the statute and in
the bill uh that this is under body art
and not under
cosmetology um so uh the question I have
for you is that the work that
cosmetologists and aestheticians do uh
is uh is is that permanent changes to
the to the facial features of the the
the
client uh representative it is a
semi-permanent um application and it's
done with a hand tool so it is a little
bit different and it does it definitely
does require um more education which is
what the border of tattooing was um
implying that they had they were putting
together so uh but it is more than one
step process sir so it's not just one
time um it's you know usually it's a
multiple um times they they do the first
treatment and then within six weeks or
so they get a second treatment and then
that is not a permanent um thing that's
something that needs to be touched up
but it definitely is a craft that needs
to be that needs to be acquired as with
any other artistic craft
followup followup thank you Mr chairman
so what I'm getting at is that that uh
women like frequently to change their
hairstyle or their look for an evening
engagement or a party or a big big du
wedding or something like that uh and
but they you know that might not be
their everyday uh choice for their their
look as I say so uh the estheticians and
cosmetologists are are are capable of of
changing a woman's style uh and and so
that what the work they produce uh is
not necessarily permanent is that
correct I don't I don't believe that's
true uh representative I think if
somebody wants to bleach their hair or
turn it red it can take up to a year to
get that out so if somebody does use a
wrong color or young and I'm speaking as
a non-c cosmetologist however I do know
from from professional from personal um
things that I've done with my hair that
it doesn't always go back right away so
I think that um those there are a lot of
things that they do that could cause
more permanent issu not semi-permanent
issues the same way meaning that it
would take a long time to turn that
around so if someone bleaches their hair
right out not always can you go back to
your original hair
color right away I'll leave it at that
thank you very much thank you there
being no more questions for M Rodriguez
thank you very much for your time uh
this time I'm going to
recognize P broadrick from the
oplc go ahead Mr
brri good morning I'm sorry uh my
computer had an issue for a second there
um so good morning members of the
committee uh I'm Tom rrick I'm legal
legal counsel at the office of
professional lure and certification or
oplc so the oplc provides administrative
and clerical support recordkeeping
services and business processing for the
54 licensing boards commissions and
councils under our
umbrella there's two oplc boards here
that are affected by this bill the Board
of barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics
and the the body art Advisory Board I
want to make clear right now I'm
speaking today on behalf of the oplc as
the agency only I'm not speaking on
behalf of either of those
boards um oplc is not taking a formal
position on this bill but I wanted to
provide the committee with some
background on the bill and the work the
agency has done to date um so first of
all I was going to go through a bit on
what microblading is but you have heard
from individuals with far more expertise
than I so I'm going to skip that part um
but several years ago I believe in 2018
cosmetologists and aestheticians sought
to be able to provide microblading to
their clients and were contacting the
board of Barber barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics about this the Board of
barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics
began working with the body at Art
advisory Council um or Advisory Board to
come up with the language that would
work several legislators uh were very
helpful with this process two of which
are on this committee um represented
Maguire and I believe repr
representative Schmidt was involved as
well though correct me if I'm wrong um
representative Maguire and Schmidt along
with representative oxenham and two
senators sponsored an identical Bill
last legislative session hb1
1416 um it was unfortunately tabled in
the Senate as you've heard due to the
pandemic but uh at that point um I
believe both boards were in favor of hb1
1416 last legislative session so knowing
that this was a priority for both boards
at the time um oplc had worked on behalf
of the boards this year to make sure
this bill was
refiled and it had been uh opl's
understanding that both boards remained
in favor this bill to date although it
sounds like some of that has changed so
as I mentioned OPC is not taking a
position on the bill um I'll note that
if the concern is public protection the
bill was structured with Public Safety
in mind so any cosmetologist or
esthetician that wishes to perform
microblading
under this bill they must first get a
microblading certificate from the body
Advisory Board um the authorities being
given to the body art Advisory Board
through op's executive director to come
up with all the requirements to obtain
and renew the microblading certificate
um those requirements would be set via
rules including all the standards of
hygiene for microblading and I I this is
the um representative goalie you had you
had addressed this exact point earlier
so in so far as the body artart Advisory
Board is the entity that has the
expertise on on the needling
hygiene that's the entity that will be
drafting these
rules to to one point of clarification
the additional twist here is the the
body art Advisory Board is an Advisory
board so um The rulemaking Authority L
does rest with the executive director of
the
oplc uh in practice what happens is the
the advisory boards under oplc are
heavily involved in
drafting um a proposed role because they
are the experts and they send it to the
executive director for review and
approval which then starts the ru making
process so the body art Advisory Board
will be heavily involved in the rul
making process on this um I think that
is all I have so thank you for your time
but I am happy to answer any questions
you may have any member of committee
have questions from Mr
brri representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman uh good morning Mr bradrick uh
thank you for being here this morning uh
I have a question with regard to um out
ofate uh training and procedures and
certificates um I I have been given to
understand that there are some uh some
procedures or some trainings in other
states
uh that seem to me to be questionable in
terms of their
adequacy um and can you speak to the uh
because I know we have worked on this
committee at Great length with regard to
doing reciprocity with other states uh
and uh you know and this is something
that I would be concerned about because
the the issue of safety has certainly
come up uh as a result of the testimony
of Mr wette and Miss Smith um and I'm
wondering uh can you speak to that issue
because to the degree that we might have
neighboring states which do not have uh
processes which we would find acceptable
uh but are producing
certificate um uh trained uh or provide
people with certificates let's put it
that way uh and Mike tried to come into
to New Hampshire and um and use their
certificates here can you talk to
that sure um so I I think you're
touching on several different things
there uh the the first point would be
that anyone that comes into the state uh
to do microblading under this bill would
need to be either a a licensed tattoo or
licensed body artist under the body art
board or under this exception um could
be a cosmetologist or aesthetician with
this certificate issued by the New
Hampshire um by New Hampshire so
um they couldn't use their Massachusetts
license to just come in here and start
practicing um the requirements to get
that certificate are set by by rule here
and the body art uh board body art
Advisory Board um can come up with
whatever however strict um requirements
they want for that it's under their
Authority um as far as reciprocity I I
would have to double check but I do not
believe the body art Advisory board has
a specific reciprocity statute there is
a general reciprocity statute I I think
it's in 332 chapter
332g um and I'm paraphrasing but I
believe it says that if a border
commission makes the determination that
um another State's license is is um
substantially similar again I'm
paraphrasing to our licenser
requirements they can allow um lure from
that other state
um I I under the hypothetically posed I
think the board could determine that um
the other state is not substantially
similar and thus could would not be
required to issue a reciprocal
license than that
any further questions Mr
Brer there being none thank you for your
testimony Mr Brer I do see uh two people
in the attendees list requesting to
speak they're not signed up to speak I'm
gonna allow it but it's going to be
short because we're on a time crunch
here so I'm going to
recognize someone named
Heidi you are recognized Heidi if you
could identify yourself
please and she has to unmute herself she
has to unmute herself but I think she's
she's disappeared I don't see her any
good morning can you hear me uh could
you speak up please and identify
yourself hi good morning um good morning
commit good morning U Mr chair can you
hear me uh we still can't hear you ma'am
um maybe you adjust your
mic try to I
apologize y we're not hearing you it's
very very
muffled try one more
time okay can you hear me
now barely if you get as close as you
can and talk loud talk as loud as you
can okay all right there you go identify
yourself please and tell us what you'd
like to say good morning can you hear
me yeah go ahead my
name um I am a licensed practitioner for
cos um for a permanent cosmetic and I am
a
microblader um I send a um ma'am ma'am
I'm gonna have to interrupt you we can't
hear you at all um it's very very
bad um perhaps we could hear hear from
the other lady Mr chairman or the other
person yeah I'm GNA um see if you can
adjust your mic I'm going to recognize
another person to testify and come back
to you and see if you can see if you can
fix that I'll give you a minute um I'm
chair is going to recognize Danielle
Ricks
Miss RX you are
recognized to speak if you unmute
yourself identify yourself
please hi representative can you hear me
okay I can thank you please identify
yourself and go
ahead sure my name is Danielle Ricks um
I'm a licensed tattoo artist and I've
been um I own and operate the brow TI um
at of Key New Hampshire and I've been in
business since
2017 and all I do is microblade eyebrows
and I also do a technique um called
powder brows which is a Cosmetic tattoo
technique that's done with the machine
it's basically the same as a tattoo
machine um I know you don't have a lot
of time so I just wanted to go over a
couple key points um that maybe someone
didn't mention before but um when I did
my training um I actually did my
training in Connecticut um it was a
4-day microblading training um at the
end of that four days my company that I
trained with um gave me a series of
tests that I had to pass in order for me
to obtain my certification so after
taking the course it took me about four
months of practicing to be able to pass
their certification um and then on top
of that I had to um get my, 1500 hours
of
apprenticeship um before I did this um I
also was a makeup artist and
and I just wanted to uh make a point
that because of that background um and
also my husband is a licensed tattoo
artist he's been a tattoo artist in the
state for almost 20 years um in no way
did those things make it easier for me
to perform microblading um I think a big
misconception is that it looks a lot
easier than it actually
is um but it's very technical um it took
me quite a while to feel comtable to be
able to do this on people's faces um
there's absolutely blood involved um you
do have to know cross contamination and
have the proper
setup um and I also wanted to make the
point that it is not semi-permanent
despite the terms being used um it is
called semi-permanent in some cases just
because touch-ups are needed um over
time to keep the complete look up but
it's very possible that some pigment uh
enter into the skin will remain over
time and it may never go away so those
are just a couple key points that I
wanted to make um but if you have any
questions please let me know uh thank
you Mr vix could you tell me um if you
are for or against the bill I don't
think you've actually said
that yeah sorry about that no I'm
actually against it um I am happy with
how the law stands currently um and I
don't think cosmetologists and
aestheticians um um necessarily have any
kind of Advantage um to doing this
technique other than maybe you know
knowing about cross contamination or
sanitation procedures but um I
apprenticed with my husband who doesn't
do tattoos on faces he does you know
like regular arms and legs but doing an
apprenticeship with him was actually
very beneficial because I learned about
cross-contamination and bloodborne
pathogens and color theory so while it
was an eyebrow specific
with him there's many things that I
learned um and I feel like a tattoo
apprenticeship of some kind is
absolutely
necessary great thank you I I appreciate
your testimony this morning um are there
any
questions there seeing none we're going
to go back I appreciate it Miss RX I'm
going to go back now to um ID and see if
we can get her mic is working or
not okay try you got to unmute
yourself good morning Mr chair can you
hear me okay no it's unfortunately it's
not any better yeah um ma'am I'm gonna
ask you to go ahead if you could to um
for the interest of time because we've
already gone over if you wish to you can
submit what you were going to say in
writing to us and we'll distribute it to
the members of the committee because we
can we can't really hear you at all okay
I apologize
no that's fine it's very challenging for
everybody to figure out how this stuff
works but please do take that take a
minute and put it in email and send it
to us and we'll make sure everybody gets
it definitely will thank you thank you
okay um with that um I see
representative Schmid you have your hand
raised I hope it's not a question for
this
witness it is not Mr chairman I think
you've made the right decision because
even though I could hear the Young
somewhat the volume was not sufficient
for the committee to be able to make use
of her
testimony as she was attempting
it but I believe this is the lady who
has written to us um and uh she is a I
believe she's a practicing uh mik will
pay attention to the written document
that
you okay um thank you represent Schmidt
you're you're actually breaking up now
as well so um with that I am going to
close um the hearing on
hb70 and we are going to break for lunch
until one o'clock one o'clock um so
thank you all very
much P if you
could so what are folks planning for
launch I know you're
um sorry
time
they're
live
oh
she made do a she made do a
co-chair
she
could you promote me to being a CO a
co-host
[Music]
please
she that
point
look like most of the committee is here
before we start the afternoon hearings I
will rep rep on the blue
sheets white
today from this
morning
425 there were three people who signed
in all in
sport
591 there were seven in for and five of
Co house 70 there were three in support
two opposed and one
M 94 there were three in
support excuse me Madam chairman could
you mute your um personal device I think
that might help the sound on our
end I could I could hear you but it was
not as clear as earlier
is that
better say a little
more
okay sound
system it seems a little garbled to me
and it looks I don't see that you're
you're
muted I will mute
myself
I muted is that better
sound um it's
not you know you're you're I can I can
understand you but it's I still don't
it's the system does not indicate that
you're
muted I I hav even joined in the
audio
huh let me see if I can mute
you didn't give me the
option it's funny representative Roy
because I I see you as muted but I can
hear you it's the microphones in the
room that are that are picking up and
that's why the devices need to be muted
because it creates an an
issue is that
better well no obviously
not wait wait wa there you go I bet try
it
now is the m your mouse are you speaking
near the microphone because I think this
happened the last time when you were
speaking away from the
microphone into the microphone is that
better yes yes that's much that's better
that's the that's the magic
combination okay I will hope that
representative
Roy be able
toote I believe I can
hearing on House
Bill representative long on
mute thank you madam chair honorable
members of the committee I'm repres
representative Pat
long um representing Hillsboro district
10 in the city of Manchester House Bill
21 is a is an effort to
um increase the time frame with which we
meet our crude
liability and um it affects no uh
current employees they stay they remain
at their current
levels uh of pension and contributions
in this um this bill
will um take effect uh January for
employees after January 1st
2022 um the only the only issue I have
is and I'm not sure that it matters but
in the analysis it mentions uh after
January 1st 2021 which should read
2022 I'm sure Rec the analysis the bill
from last year right
okay and uh Mr flurry who's the
executive director retired uh Friday but
was kind enough to
articulate uh the this these both bills
better uh I believe is also here and I
thank you and any
questions I have one question and that's
really why is this coming before the
legislature if it's purely a city of
Manchester issue we need to make sure
that
your your retirement system is run
fairly and trustees
arear but other than that why we
involv yeah Mr flurry could address that
my understanding is that it's tied into
the state and we need this approval to
change
it are there any other questions from
the
committee Madam chair I have my hand up
oh thank you representative
please
speak thank you madam chair and thank
you representative long for taking my
question
um and this bill increases
rates for new
highes um um to pay the city's unfunded
liability at this time do you think
that's prudent to be doing when I
believe the city's having a tough enough
time filling some of the positions it
has to ask those that they are trying to
recruit to pay more so that they can pay
off uh some of the unfunded ACR
liability that the city itself is um
obtained well thank you representative
for the question
and personal I don't again those
employees that are currently in the
system have no changes this would be for
new employees that would agree to the um
conditions set forth in this uh and
frankly as a 24 year old getting into a
union I was looking for what goes in my
pocket I really didn't study the pension
or other benefits um so I I don't I
don't believe this is going to deter
people from wanting to be hired
in looking for what's going into your
pocket when you're going to be getting
less going in because you're paying more
towards a retirement cost for an
unfunded liability that you didn't have
any part
in wouldn't that be part of the money
going in your pocket seeing you're
making that much less than those hired
before you yeah no I I I agree as
um being a little more mature I would be
looking at that but at you know in my
20s and 30s what's going in my pocket I
don't know what's being taken out yet uh
for dues or whatever however you know I
look at what's going in my pocket so I
don't really believe that this my
understanding in in the determin from
people being hired is the salary uh
which the city of Manchester
addressed thank
you um I have a a question it's as much
a comment as it is a question so you're
proposing that it's not hurtful because
they're not looking at what's coming out
of their
paycheck is that
satisfactory thank you for the question
representative I I I don't believe that
it I don't believe that somebody looking
for a
job knows exactly what to look for with
respect to benefits what they're paying
for benefits however I do know somebody
who accepts a job will accept these
condition I conditions on their
pension followup please so in a time
when people are needing
jobs it sounds to me like the
proposition is that if we can take
advantage of them we will uh and I'm I'm
sorry uh but um that cuts right to the
chase of it in my
opinion well I I I I
disagree thank
you about 3 minutes early we got here
just on time I apologize if this has
been covered and I don't know who to
address it to but my question is is the
Manchester pension system completely
separate from the state one yes it is
okay thank you this applies to
theity of Manchester it does not apply
to police fire teachers who are in the
state thank
you can you hear me without un
muting um
no thank you just a quick question um
does this have any collective bargaining
implication just got potential for Union
litigation can you speak to that
yeah my understanding Mr flurry would
have a more articulate answer but my
understanding is this is a management
right we are the we have a member
representative of the
AF speaking next so I'm sure that person
will
be
questions James jerkin
please
hi madam Sher can you hear me okay yes
thank you thank you uh Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
Jim Durkin legislative agent for ask me
Council 93 proudly representing 4,000
public sector workers in New Hampshire
including over 200 men and women working
in multiable departments for the city of
Manchester and a wide array of jobs
ranging from snowplow drivers to School
nurses and I'm here today on their
behalf and on behalf of those who will
fill these jobs in the future to oppose
House Bill 211 uh for starters we oppose
the legislation because we fundamentally
disagree with any effort to unfairly
shift any additional amount of the
funding liability onto the backs of
hardworking public employees even those
who have yet to be hired we also oppose
increasing minimum age requirements
especially for workers that have stous
job responsibilities such as our public
sector workers you know just requiring
to work beyond the age already
established in current law is not only
unfair but it creates a higher
likelihood of serious injury and from a
taxpayers point of view could subject
the municipality to costly workers comp
and other Financial liabilities for a
city but what's really important for
this committee to know is the brief
history behind this legislation it's a
refile from the previous session and
suffice to say things have changed
significantly since then and while the
proposed changes may have had the
support of a majority of the city's
Retirement Board in the past composition
of this board has changed and the
proposed changes in this bill no longer
uh enjoy the support of at least three
of the seven members of the current
board quite possibly more and this is
due in no small part to a recent report
from the board's pension Consultants on
Friday I spoke personally with dick
Molen the chair of the Retirement Board
who informed me that their Consultants a
group called uh New England pension
Consultants informed the board just last
month that they're now on track to meet
their required funding obligations
without making these proposed changes Mr
Mullen told me he doesn't support the
changes and authorized me to relay that
to you today uh in addition over the
weekend I also spoke personally to two
other members of the Retirement Board uh
Matt session and Tom bazo both told me
they're opposed to making these changes
and like Mr Mullen both authorized me to
convey their opposition to you today so
that's three of the seven members of the
board right there in addition to not
having The Firm support of the current
Retirement Board these proposed changes
have yet to be heard by and voted on by
the Manchester City Board of Alderman
and it's fair to say there's
questionable support on that board as
well in fact the alderman is slated to
weigh in on the matter at their meeting
tomorrow night while the new Retirement
Board is slated to meet one week from
tomorrow to discuss these changes they
have not had an opportunity to meet yet
on it as stated at the onset of my
testimony we oppos the legislation on
its merits or lack thereof and we ask
that you support us in this opposition
however given the AFF forementioned
change and support at the Retirement
Board the positive report from the
board's experienced professional
consultants and the uncertainty of the
pending action of the Alderman and the
Retirement Board we would respectfully
request that at the very least this
committee re uh refrain from any further
action until at least such time as the
Retirement Board and Alderman have had a
chance to act Liber at on the matter
finally in closing I also spoke this
morning with Manchester uh mayor Joyce
Craig who as an ex officio member of the
Retirement Board would cast a vote in
the event of a three to3 tie and she
said I could convey her request that you
delay action on this bill until the new
Retirement Board and Alderman have had a
chance to weigh in so uh I thank you for
your time and consideration I'll do my
best to answer any questions that
members of the committee may have and
Madam chair I wanted to be under three
minutes out of respect to the committee
but if I could add one more thing based
on what I heard prior to my
testimony uh thank you uh re uh rep
goalie I believe mentioned uh the
problem of recruitment I can tell you
from talking to our members up there
that recruitment is a problem and this
will exacerbate it uh they mentioned one
position in particular uh an
electrician's position that's been
posted for several months and uh you
know you to be the the municipal jobs
may not have paid too much but the
benefit in getting there and sticking
there was the benefits and the
retirement and under this bill you're
essentially you're asking them to pay
almost double what the contribution
rates were you're asking them to work
longer and you're basing the pension
benefit now on five years average
earning as opposed to three so by
reducing this benefit you are going to
you are going to uh create a recruitment
problem uh but most importantly really
you know we would urge you to to to you
know this is a local bill as was pointed
out it's local changes the Alderman and
the new Retirement Board and the new
Alderman really should have a chance to
weigh in on this and convey how they
feel to this committee before the
committee acts thank you
again thank
you did I hear you correctly to say that
the Manchester City retirement system
is is properly funded or on track to
being so that was relayed to me by uh uh
Mr Mullen who's the chair of the board
and that was based on a Consultants
report uh that they received I believe
just last month and the group is called
New England pension Consultants they're
a reputable organization they've been in
business for almost 35 years uh doing
this kind to
work thank you very much are there any
other questions
Mr representative
Roy thank you taking my
question um with regard to new hes I
guess it's probably not a collective
bargain of issue but if they were to try
and increase it on current members of
the system would that then
Collective
produtions I I believe it would
representative not uh not my my area of
work for the union I do not negotiate
contracts but it is something that we
would certainly uh you know certainly
argue should be the subject of of
negotiations thank you sir other
questions being none
I'll I'll call Gerard
slurry
might have to unmute
yourself I'm working on
it can you hear me now
yeah Madame chairman can you uh please
acknowledge that you can hear me yes I
can hear you thank
you thank you madam chairman uh for the
record my name is Gerard flurry I am the
uh executive chairman emeritus of the
New Hampshire the Manchester employees
contributor retirement system I
technically retired last Friday uh a
little bit about my uh my background was
with the city at at Manchester
retirement for 17 years I was with the
New Hampshire retirement system for more
than 25 years prior to that and my uh my
expertise in this area is extensive I'm
hearing to speak in favor of the
legislation and to perhaps address a few
of the questions that I've heard come up
in testimony uh prior to this uh one of
the questions is why is this before the
legislature uh Manchester is like every
other and my Public Employee Retirement
System uh has to be a qualified plan
according to section 401 A9 of the
Internal Revenue code section four 401
A9 says when you have a state or local
Municipal plan and you're amending any
of the provisions of the plan it must be
be done through a state legislature
Manchester does not have the authority
to make these changes on their own so
really this is is the legislator one of
the questions is why is this perform a
legislature ability to empower
Manchester to make change
uh I also heard has to
be99 says when you have a States was
fair the rate increases were going to be
fair to people are going to be hired
prospectively I might point out that
these rates whether it be the fiveyear
averaging the contribuition amount are
exactly the so really this is the legisl
of the same as the New Hampshire
retirement system is now so perhaps
there's a bit of catch up there uh the
plan was studied for a period of a
number must be of years through
Manchester power Manchester to make
changes our actuary G actuary Gabriel
Roden Smith and the trustees at the time
were very concerned right now for one
this was increase pce make additional 30
cents the board was concerned that if
that number grew much larger that the
plan might not be sustainable so if the
concern is what's going to happen to
future people you plan was study happen
if that rate grew so high that like many
other public C pay an additional if that
number grew much larger that the plan
might not be sustained shut down a
defined benefit and go to a defined
contribution that certainly would not be
in the best interest of your future
employees in fact it was the opinion of
the board up until the recent election
that uh the retirement system really
helped to attract and retain perhaps
elction that places in the public sector
where you can still find a defined
benefit plan one that will pay you the
kind of benefit and R Trust at the time
now for every dollar in wages the
changes were essentially to lower the
board was concerned that noral
retirement 62 in the 17 years I was
there like many years I was there I can
tell you that there are a lot of people
that worked right Beyond retire the
normal retirement age and they did so
for other reasons it's true that if you
have people that are in very uh
stressful uh that demanding positions
going to
62 would be more difficult that was a a
dilemma the board had to cope with and
it did consider
that the other thing is that essentially
to lower the normal retirement age City
underpaying the discount amount so that
they were getting better than a fair
deal this was brought to the attention
of the Retirement Board by its actuary
so one of the things that would seek
that that this bill would seek to do
it's true that you have is to create to
to correct that fact to bring it back to
normal actuarials uh physically and U I
guess in in closing uh what this bill
would do to the unfunded acrude
liability
would be to cause it to be paid off
about a year ahead of time and if you
look at how unfunded acrude liabilities
work it's very discount amount very
similar to a home mortgage when you're
paying on at the beginning of the
mortgage almost nothing goes to
principle and everything to interest and
acrude liability Works in a similar
fashion so that in what this would allow
you to do is accelerate the payment near
the end would see this bill essentially
save the city about $14 million over the
next uh decade or so the unfunded ACR
liability is scheduled to be uh uh
retired in uh
2039 we scheduled to be uh similar build
to this in the session last year which
didn't reach completion because of the
co
situation in the Edna committee there
were amendments made to that bill so
that when the acred liability was
satisfi it's very satisfied that that
cost revision would switch back uh the
board had no difficulty with those
provisions and they are Incorporated in
uh the language in 20111 so uh again U
I've been doing this for many many years
I believe that the board when it studied
this and acted upon it acted in the in
the best interest of the fund and the
fund and the best interest of not only
existing workers but future workers uh
there was also a little bit of uh
confusion about a report that came
retired and similar came from with with
the current situation it is true that
we're that we're on target for earnings
assumptions that has nothing to do with
funding requirements it's an apples an
orange situation the fund is expected to
make its uh its uh funding obligation
and meet its earnings expectations out
for the next 20 years so the board had
notion on that uh that is all again the
committee would want to place emphasis
one thing that is acted in the the best
under normal circumstances this would
have gone to the board of marinal and
earlier than this and we would have been
able to come to you with some something
where that had a log of the vot of the
log of the V of the of the BMA has
fortunately the way the time for
earnings assumption scheduled until
tomorrow night it would have been far
preferable if we had been able to do
that earlier and I could have come to
you today saying this is how the the
board uh of Mayor Alderman uh felt about
the issue this was their vote
unfortunately again those uh that
schedule is Revol funding obligation a
measure of Correction but uh again in
closing I was asked to speak on behalf
of the bill uh if you have any other
questions I'd be glad to answer them
thank you earlier than this had a log of
the vote of the the BMA scheduled until
tomorrow night saying this is how the
board thank
you are there any questions members of
the
committee
uh uh thank you madam
chair uh Mr flurry you gave me your
testimony uh you re decided is it a
federal statute or a state the 401 could
you give me that and is it state or
federal so I could do the research on
that
please yes certainly uh that's section
4189 of the Internal Revenue
code and in order order for any public
uh fund or Municipal Fund in any of the
50 states to meet the standards of being
a qualified plan and this in essence
that means that the the income the
income tax is exempt for the pension
fund on any of their investment earnings
you have to be a qualified plan and if
you are and you want to amend any of the
language to creates that plan it must
grow through the legislature in one of
the 50
states
okay follow up if I may mam thank you um
I know you're not tied or any
affiliation with the NRS system but the
uh nhrs system does have a two-tier
similar to what you want to put or is
recommended in this particular bill that
means and as you go on into the future
as older workers drop off and the
younger ones you come down to the older
workers will be smaller in number and
they'll be paying less and already
there's that push back that we see in
the nhrs system uh because the younger
members coming in are under a a
different thing do you anticipate that
same potential animosity uh in
Manchester because of
this the board considered that and
that's why the language was crafted such
that it would only affect people not yet
working for the for the city we thought
that there would be a certain degree of
push back from existing members if the
plan were made effective for everyone
immediately we had seen that happen when
the nhrs increased its its member
contribution uh rate and that was a
nasty situation that went as far as the
state supreme court we wanted to avoid
that and so the board thought that the
best way to do it would be to enact it
in such a way that no one who is
currently in on the scene would be
adversely affected and then reflecting
on it further again as I State stated if
you can find any kind of an employer
offering a defined benefit plan for only
a 5% contribution rate with the the the
balance being for a medical subsidy so
the total contribution rate would be
seven and uh if you can find that
anywhere uh it's an
audity thank you for taking my questions
thank you madam
chair are there other
questions thank you very
much is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on this
bill Mr
Durkin Mr deren you're
on okay Mr
Derk yes uh Madame chair can you hear me
okay now yes I just would like to
reiterate uh it I I apologize a lot of
the a lot of the stuff bad connection I
couldn't hear from from Mr flurry but
just I I think it's it's a common sense
and logic that given all the unanswered
questions and again uh the the uh
conversation I had with mayor Craig this
morning the chief executive for the city
we would respectfully ask no action be
taken on this until the alderman can uh
work on this and and discuss it tomorrow
night and most importantly until the new
Retirement Board has an opportunity to
actually vote on this a week from
tomorrow and I thank you again for your
time thank you we we will not act on it
today that's for
sure so there anyone else wishes to
speak uh Madam chair may I ask a
parliamentary inquiry yes I may thank
you madam chair uh would it behoove us
to uh send a letter via the committee to
uh the mayor of Manchester saying that
we would uh we would like to hear the
opinions of herself and the board on
this particular matter as expens
exponentially as possible please
um good idea I'll I'll do that thank you
madam
chair okay
so opening the hearing oh
in there were three people signed in in
favor who and three oo and two
opposed the open the hearing on House
Bill 356 which is also relative to the
Manchester retirement system and I call
Representative
law thank thank you madam chair
honorable members of the committee uh
again representative Pat long Hillsboro
district 10 within the city of
Manchester and uh Madam chair for your
edification the uh the board tomorrow
will be voting on to or opposes so
Wednesday morning the committee will get
that certified vote um excellent that
save writing a
letter it'll save you from writing a
letter yeah what Wednesday morning we
could send you the results of that vote
um House Bill 356 Rel relative to the uh
Manchester contributive retirement
system uh this bill helps clarify uh
language uh Internal Revenue code uh
Treasury regulations and how to um how
to fulfill uh um an elected trustee who
resigns how to fulfill that spot uh and
again Mr flurry's here if there are any
questions uh regarding this bill thank
you madam
chair representative leus just a
suggestion and that is um since Mr
flurry seems to have a bad internet
connection if you could ask him to turn
his camera off it might help yes thank
you uh representative excuse me Mr
flurry you're called on to speak and
representative laus suggests that you
turn your camera off so that the audio
could be better we're having a little
trouble uh your connection isn't as as
strong as you might like
all right uh thank you madam chairman I
have uh I have shut my camera down is my
audio coming through better now yes much
thank you very much for
that uh Madam chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Gerard flurry I the executive director
Meritus for the Manchester employees
contributory retirement system I'm here
today to testify in favor of House Bill
356 is before the committee uh similar
uh bill was uh submitted last year under
HB 39 uh of 1293 made it as far as
committee with an ought to pass and then
halted when the uh uh bill was U uh
tabled because of the covid situation uh
HB uh 356 is purely administrative in
nature uh one of the situations that has
uh uh troubled the uh the Board of
Trustees in recent years at city of
Manchester is that if uh if a trustee
for any reason is unable to to finish
their elected term that they're short of
holding a special election there were uh
there was no provision to be able to
fill that Gap uh generally it's a small
board a lot of important decisions were
made are made and it seemed uh uh normal
that there ought to be some form of uh
Authority where whereby the trustees
could appoint an individual to fill a
vacancy until the next regularly
scheduled election that's common
practice in the number of cities and
towns other organizations throughout New
Hampshire so uh in order to be able to
do that a statutory Amendment to the
plan was required and this bill would
would accomplish that uh the other thing
that this bill does is to help with
compliance and ease compliance with uh
federal reporting requirements uh any
time that the uh that the federal
authorities uh engage in revised rules
or regulations dealing with public plans
it's normally required that uh plans
come before their local legislatures to
seek compliance sometimes those are very
uh minor matters could be the order in
which things are filed and or the like
uh in getting a uh a private letter
ruling uh in
2017 uh we were able to negotiate with
the IRS and they agreed that rather than
have to come before the legislature for
minor housekeeping items that we could
do it through Ru making within the city
and whenever something like that would
happen uh a rule change would be posted
for 30 days there would be a public
hearing on it and then the board could
act to amend uh the the tax reporting
aspects of the plan in order to stay in
full compliance with the IRS but again
in order to be able to do that we need
needed an item of uh empowerment from
the state legislature that would allow
us to introduce future items strictly
related to uh federal tax law so that it
could be handled locally through rul
making and that's what this bill would
do so again uh I would uh greatly
appreciate support of the committee on
this bill and I'm prepared to answer any
other questions you might
have thank you are there questions
you said till the next election are your
trustees
elected uh the board is a composite uh
there are two individuals the uh the
mayor and the City Finance director that
are ex official members of the board
then the uh the mayor gets to appoint a
trustee the alderman get to appoint a
trustee and there are three elected two
of the elected members are members of
the system that is to say current
employees of the of the city and one of
them is simply needs to be a resident of
the city so of those three elected
positions within the last few years we
had an individual that uh had to retire
on a work-related ability and could not
finish their term and then we had
another individual that had uh a slate
of personal problems and had to resigned
from the board the board was powerless
to fill those positions uh short of
having to conduct a special
election thank you other
questions thank you Mr flurry for the uh
committee's report there are three
people signed in all in
support and is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
356 okay seeing none I will close the
public
hearing our
next bill is scheduled to start the
hearing is at
2:15
so
uh I think I will entertain motions on
Bill bills that we have heard and that
are ready to be voted out of
committee questions everybody everybody
on the committee
here everyone on the committee has
signed in today representative Judy now
has
video um I'd like to make an itail
motion on
274 all right that's all
right okay Representative leus makes a
motion that house bill 274 which is the
contribution of the state toward local
retirement issues be in expedient to
legislate is there a second I
second who was that
please representative
groa
okay would you like to speak to your
motion representative
leus yes
um
so let me make sure
I this is as I understand this is the
one that um has the state paying
5% uh no I don't this is the one
where actually I have the wrong bill I
would I'm sorry I'd like to withdraw
that it was I wanted to do it on uh the
one related to extending the uh
House Bill 390 yeah sorry about that I'd
like to make an itail motion on House
Bill 390
oh right sorry for the confusion
representative leus actually meant House
Bill
390 which is to stretch out the unfunded
liability is there a second to that I
think it
was I'm sorry I had the same number
problem that representative le le had
fine do you seconded motion anyway yes I
do Madam chair okay thank you
representative leus would you care to
speak on your motion I would
um I mean the downside for this is that
it uh it's going to cost the taxpayers
an extra 1.4 billion over time it's uh
you know we've heard it's going to cost
$2 for every uh dollar that's deferred
in the short term and the issue is
there's almost always um Financial
pressures I mean that's sort of the
nature both of uh people's personal
budgets and certainly those of
government as well pressure for more
services and people don't want their
taxes raised so there's always going to
be temptation to do this but it's you
know in the same sense as people uh
putting everything on the credit card
bill you just uh you end up paying
dramatically more in the long run and
just push out the time in which you Mo
up you know you're actually have fullly
funded and when this is fully paid off
the current schedule is
2039 the amount the employers of the
municipalities County and the state will
have to pay that the uh retirement
system will will decrease
substantially and um you know arguably
30 years was uh was kind of long um as
it was given that a uh you know private
Pension Plan would
uh be allowed no more than seven years
do
that I mean we heard the argument that
uh in a sense that a uh public Pension
Plan can't go broke I'm not sure that's
going to turn out to be true there's
some states that are looking like they
may get into trouble that way but even
if it were true um it's still charging
you know making taxpayers pay a lot more
and the worst part of that is that that
money is going to come from people in
the future we're already talking um 19
years out I mean so you're going to have
people who are children now or you know
potentially a small number who are not
yet born um who are going to be uh stuck
paying this money because we don't want
to um you know make up for past mistakes
now so I'd argue we you know it's not
right to be pushing this further out
thank you representative BR would you
like to speak to your
second it sets an unwarranted precedence
and it is an unwise use of the taxpayers
dollars thank
you does anyone else wish to speak
represent
s I'm not sure this is worth it but let
me say it briefly I was here in the 90s
when I saw some of this Mischief
unfolding and it hurt like it hurt to
see it then and it hurts to see it now
because the pain of nasua is real but
the medicine medine will be worse than
the disease so this is just this is just
very unfortunate all
around does anyone else wish to speak on
House Bill
390 yes Madam chair I don't think you
can see my little representative Schulz
yes thank you I'm not quite that my eyes
aren't quite that good please speak
thank you madam chair I just want to
make sure um to the SP sponsor uh
representative O'Brien I am very EMP I
think we're all empathetic to what the
mayor of nashille is facing and I know
you also serve as a council member in
Alderman and I think that um finding
ways to reduce the burdens being
downshifted to the cities and towns is a
high priority for many of us if not all
of us I hope um and the property
taxes in most towns and cities uh is
horrible and I hope that he doesn't take
this as a sign that we aren't committed
to tackling that with his help and I
believe um we really do need to find
better Solutions but I'm fortunately
gonna oppose this bill because this is
just not the right way in my
opinion thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to speak yeah Madam chair
representative
O'Brien yes represent O'Brian please
thank you and uh I would really like to
thank uh uh representative uh Schultz
and thank the whole committee uh I'm
smart enough to realize when I'm
Shoveling sand against the tide here but
the thing is I want to express to you
the city of
nashar did not ask for this this was
handed down by the state
legislature okay and it was left to NASA
to come up and it's not just nashwa may
I offer you need to talk to each and one
of your own representative on your town
councils and everything if you have one
employe into the uh nhrs you are
suffering what past legisl
have done to this uh I feel content I
you know try to come up with a solution
but I feel content that I have
identified a legitimate problem that
most certainly needs to be resolved I'll
hold my breath and hold my hopes maybe
uh for
274 uh I hope uh that may uh meet the
standards of this committee but I really
like to thank you all for your careful
consider ation on this matter and uh
even though I will vote and support uh I
just love being on Edna now thank
you thank you very
much all right any other
comments
questions I have a question yes
representative I've just returned and I
take it here an executive session and do
you want me to vote or not if you are
here I want you to vote
okay
okay is there any other comments
questions seeing
none the uh the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 390 and the
clerk will call the
RO
yes
yes yes representa
representative yes
representa yes
representa
yes
represent
representative
yes representative
Judy
representative yes that was
yes representative
schz
yes
representative
represent
yes representative broen
yes representative O'Brian
no and no minority rep
[Laughter]
put
yes do you object to consent
representative O'Brien not at all thank
you madam
chair Madam chair yes
I would like to move HP 536 relative to
the death benefits uh one-time death
benefits for Public Works employees
ought to
pass second by
Smit thank you I believe we had a motion
on that one
already we just we sorry I didn't hear
that I understand it
was we were discussing 536 last time and
and I actually don't think we had
discussion but we did not have a motion
so the motion is from representative
Schulz is ought to pass second by
representative
Schmidt okay representative Schultz if
you care to speak to your motion yes
ma'am um this had uh almost by uh
unanimous consent uh before covid it was
uh 15 to4 it passed in the house before
on a Bo vote and this is one of those
uh but for covid it would have um
succeeded so um I hope that you will
support this bill it uh is an
unfortunate thing that we need it at all
um I do believe that these Public Works
employees at the town and state level
are First Responders and have very risky
dangerous jobs and I think this is the
right thing to
do thank you Schmid do you wish to speak
to your second thank you I do Madam
chair briefly this is a situation these
people are at enormous risk darting in
out of traffic with regard to U their
jobs it's a miracle that we don't have
more injuries and
fatalities um but maybe they just
learned to uh Dodge Dodge bullets so um
let's protect them as rare as it is
let's protect them when it
happens thank you is there anyone else
who would like representative please uh
thank you madam chairman chairwoman we
haven't even discussed okay you want to
be a chair all right you got it um I sat
on the original subcommittee last time
with uh representative Shu and
one other I think it may have been
representative Fox I can't remember but
uh in this is this is bringing back
language from that subcommittee work
last time um I've you know I've worked
with uh with the Department of
Transportation and other folks on the
highway for over 20 years in my fire
service career and I am going to be
supporting this bill it's a rare event
it certainly is financially devastating
to the families they would certainly
much rather have their loved
one on top of the the loss of the
paycheck and all that so I I think this
to me is an easy one so I I'm just
rendering my support thank
you other members of the committee
comments
questions all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
536 by representative Schulz seconded by
representative schm the clerk will call
the role representa yes
yes
representative
yes representative
y
yes
representative yes
representative yes representative
Laro yes Representative
santoo
no representative goalie
yes representative sure
absolutely representative Judy
we representative Schmid yes
representative
Schultz in the memory of the band who
inspired this Bill
yes representative follows
yes
representative
representative Broda yes representative
o'ri
yes and the
chair
yes
um excuse me represento do you plan to
write a Minority
Report uh no Minority Report okay what's
the vote again Madam chair the what vote
the vote was 18 to one 18 to1 thank you
and uh what's the bill number I'm sorry
I just come in from the cold
136 sorry 536 almost the
same Madam chair is it appropriate to
put this onent count on
what consent
does anyone object to consent
anyone hearing none in that case we'll
put it on
consent okay representative Roy has a
motion on
HB
619 Des police fire dispatches gr memb
of the retirement system oh sorry we've
already retained that sorry no we did
yeah here I have a
motion I'm sorry this is
representative I have a
motion please give us your motion
OTP right this
sound I'll spill 70 yes the micro
eyebrow one I'll second that oh m come
to
sure the motion is ought to pass on
House Bill 70 by representative grota
and I I
second you wish to speak to your motion
representative Bara I'll second that
this is a bill that we heard last year
and went through this committee with no
issue and I don't see an issue
again I see I think it's fine the way it
is thank
you thank you in response to my second
I'd like to say that the concerns raised
by the tattoo artist should largely be
resolved by the fact this bill gives
them full authority to set the standards
for the
training because we don't know enough
about what's required to set what they
ought to be but they do and that's all I
want to
say representative scitec thank you will
those uh will that training
is that a matter of rule will let go
before jail car yes the reason I'm
asking is uh I would not like to see the
rules made so
prohibitive that it's basically a veto
of the bill
andth to set that's what we will have to
watch for the training representative
Pearson do you have a comment or
question what they to be I'm trying to
figure out why the television's on about
a 14c delay with an echo
represent representative Schultz are you
are you trying to speak will those no
ma'am uh will that
training is that a matter of
rule let go
before yes yes exactly reason I'm ask is
that's that's history uh I would not
like to see the rules made step back in
time there are quite a few people that
aren't muted that would probably fix
it let's try
that okay is there anyone else who
wishes to
speak I do we ask representative
Schmidt thank you so uh as much as I
would not like to have to have this
procedure done on me I'm not
fundamentally opposed to the uh uh to
the practice if it's done by somebody
who knows what the hell they're doing uh
and so I think it behooves us I haven't
decided whether I'm going to vote no as
a protest against uh the not as a
warning against the possibility that uh
that the the rules will be too weak I I
don't want it to be prohibited either
but this is not some weekend uh course
uh for somebody who's a A cosmotologist
or esthetician this is serious business
to be experiment not experiment but to
to be um operating on a woman's face or
a man's face for that matter uh with
something that's effectively going to be
permanent so we have to it behooves us
to make sure that these rules really do
uh require the necessary training and it
it it won't be
brief yes thank you representative schm
representative leus um so is my
understanding correct that actually the
rules for tattooing are not set down in
statute but are actually generated by
the uh the board and it's the same board
that would be coming up with the rules
for this microing you are correct the
only requirement set in statute is the
minimum one year of apprentic the
only represent
goalie thank you madam chair I just want
to uh state that I will be supporting
this uh my concerns that that have been
raised to me
uh I have no longer have um looking at
the requirements that will be done by uh
recommendations made by the body art
board um along with the approval of the
courses and um any of the health issues
because the standards of hygiene for
performing microblading will be part of
the rules process so uh I will support
this thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to
speak represent are you wish to speak no
ma'am I am in support thank you anyone
else all right then the motion is ought
to pass on House Bill 70 by
representative Broda the cler will call
the role represent yes thank you there
anyone
else yes
representative yes representative laus
yes yes representative Alro yes
representative Bailey
yes representative
lar
yes the motion is to
pass yes representative Roy yes
representative cler Bruce
yes
representative representative
representative laus yes representative
lro representative Bailey yes
representative
lanzara representative Santo
naso Oh I thought I was already called
yes yeah
it's an echo of the video we should all
mute ourselves till our name is called
as my suggestion what there's no
microphone on that computer so yeah
that's why I just who was calling the
role it wasn't
representative it was a replay of his
earlier
rooll JY yeah was a delay like 30 second
all right uh continue representative
scitec
representative
representative Peter
bar yes yeah I will vote
Yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative Fel yes representative BR
yes
representan yes
and yes
does anyone object to
consent hearing none we will put this
one on
consent uh I think we
will yes Madam chair excuse me did I
hear correctly that rep Schmidt did vote
Yes on this after he
did thank you I just with all the
echoing that I got that correct
uh I think we will take a 15 minute
recess to figure out why our why we're
getting this Echo the hearing for house
build 209 20:09 will begin at 2:15
pm. and for all those who made motions I
need your your blurbs as soon as
possible
so is there when they're going consent
they still need one they still need even
more so because what you need to do yeah
here but I have my audio turned off
that's just so I can see because I can't
see that if you're if it's on consent
your goal is not only to convince people
to vote the way you want it's to
convince them to leave it
on
as as long as it needs to be right I I
tend not to be
that mine tend to be relatively concise
I
beautifuler did it include
poetry it was poetical
sort
that tomorrow morning soon
enough sometime tomorrow is a snow again
we don't don't absolutely need it for
two weeks
no I'm not I'm not going to go longer
than that did even figure out
how they're I've heard rumors that maybe
it'll be sort of like the hockey
rly there
maybe we get
actually
that's I get little
better
no I don't want it I wanted
to
El
people I think that just getting that
forward helps with the because
these
things
and
I don't know why
that the issue I have is I can normally
hear pretty well but if there's
background noise it's more difficult so
this has been that helped a little bit
so thank you um but it's
still for some
people so the the reason the chairs
might didn't
work
doing pretty well
on you want there's time later we could
probably acct 130
okay his his testimony convinced me go
his
way but the second
Manch
like
the second
one the one about someone leaving office
and their ability to oh
to and and to be able to accommodate
changes in IR schs by
their the room set up yes if it's
possible would it be easier to help with
both viewing the screen and so with
audio since as long as there only five
or six or seven
of move it up and then when the room
fills up we got to go back there with it
that's a good
idea I'm not gonna touch it today no
kill the meeting probably never yeah I
had to actually that speaker when I
moved it sorry you had to move the power
I had to I had to move the power that
but I had to also go through on the top
there's a chart where it takes Bluetooth
RCA oh uh WiFi and I had toy that's
why SC I'm like tell somebody to talk
because I got to figure out what setting
oh on the speaker on the speaker to get
it to come
out multi
speaker yeah
I yes it
was that's
the
it's a good day that's actually one got
it running on my phone so I can see
people
pict audio disabled I don't know the
voices yet you
[Music]
know sign to I
don't sending it to
us
people people can be as offended as
they so that's okay I say nothing I
can't justify
with usually I'm better
always
people oh
yeah yeah
they
like yeah it's like
when Lun
picture
talks
IND
I'm
sure yes I'm sure it
is
assoc
I don't own anything in man
either I just I just deal with them when
they burn
down might be an issue I've got
uh I think it's 412 Central banded
building next to it I that next
door there's in it outside door that was
a while is it does it have a big red X
the white
remember yes exactly it's
not music 68 people signed up
support how many to speak I
think no
there's
theologists
areos the is
neutral it
was it's
just oh what's funny is my
mother-in-law father
down Texas where brother Liv so we got
call snow your is pretty good about
during the be a b deal I got snow tires
that's why I say to my wife I'm like
look I jump in the one time whether I
plow three inches or I plow eight inches
I I just
plow my husband congratulated me
oning it shouldn't be too bad tonight
next two days
oh there you
go th everything should be old and
honestly after the January we just had
we shouldn't
complain like nothing we probably need
some
sow Rivers
so the rail Trails they don't make snow
on the RO so that's
true
[Music]
the trails are all they're making sell
like crazy up there yeah but I wonder
how
much yeah skiing is something you can do
by yourself away from other people my
wife and I made the decision to not even
I don't feel like
getting scar
brought my
school so have you been sking they
bother
people I
don't I enough balance to
walk actually my my left leg's almost an
Shor my
right
start just start on the right and you'll
just work your way over by the time you
get to the bottom be good I walk
together hold
hands I could I don't like I did that
and what happened is one of my legs my
left leg stopped before my
wife up I
to
yeah I was careful and I came in I sat
down about three minutes
ear play
Screech
the Screech and the TV
show
yeah mine stopped working sometime last
year they they uh they canel most of
them during the
shut wellard I mean when I came in back
from lunch I actually had a beat on the
door to get them to come to it and said
don't you have a c and I said doesn't
work I said well down
to M mine stopped working before and I
just
got
I'm all right no more
exective day and bang it out
this
is
okay we're back I hope the uh system has
calmed down I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 209 and I call Representative
McGee who's the time
sponsor
muted representa M you'll have to unmute
yourself representative McGee I just
realized that it's it's a zoom thing
thank you so much uh thank you madam
chairwoman and members of the executive
departments and administration committee
for having us here today and for hearing
uh hb29 a bill that was improved by Edna
in a subcommittee last session and was
ready to pass into law when covid-19 had
its way with it uh I'm representative
McGee of Hillsboro 27 Hollis and I'm the
prime sponsor of the bill which has a
twin bill on the Senate side this time
around sponsored by Senator Kevin avard
so um he and I have discussed the bill
uh and support for this legislation um
however he was too late to sign on to my
bill so I'm actually on his bill and I
would like you to consider this bill to
be a bipartisan effort U because of that
excuse me representative McGee yes did
you say there's an identical bill in the
Senate it is my understanding that
representative avart also filed uh
similar language
yes thank you you're welcome um so
although there are experts here today
who can provide testimony uh relative to
both music therapy as a profession and
the need for licensure to delineate what
a qualified music therapist is and is
not I would like to Simply address uh
some nuts and bolts of the definition of
music therapy for you just as a starter
um music therapy is an Allied Health
profession similar to physical
occupational or speech therapy a board
certified music therapist utilizes uh
music based activities to address social
emotional physical communicative and
cognitive domains on an individualized
basis research in music therapy supports
its Effectiveness in many areas such as
overall physical rehabilitation
facilitating movement increasing
people's avenues for communication that
can be helpful to those who find it
difficult to expresss in words research
in music therapy supports its
Effectiveness in many such uh uh areas
uh such as overall physical
rehabilitation and facilitating movement
increasing people's motivation to engage
in their treatment providing emotional
support for clients and their families
and providing an outlet for again
expressions of feeling um examples of
Music based activities include
songwriting lyric analysis instrument
playing music and movement Andor
improvisation music therapists work with
all populations including Behavioral
Health and Military populations autism
spectrum disorder and other
developmental disabilities Alzheimer's
disease persons in Correctional and
forensic facilities and in response to
crisis and Trauma within medical
settings and in collaboration with music
educators and team uh other team
collaborations on a personal note my
family actually had an 18-year-old
member who broke his neck diving into a
pool this past summer and when he was
going through a serious rehabilitation
in Spalding uh music therapy was the
preferred modality that they said they
had seen improvements in people with
spinal cord injury so I just wanted to
say that because I have my own personal
experience now um RSA 328 F uh governing
Allied Health Professions would be
modified by this bill to include
licensed music
therapists um in accordance with the
language that was modified by members of
this house committee so the bill that
you have before you has the modified
language of the most recent
Amendment uh first and foro foremost
that is the aim is to recognize this
well established profession in the state
of New Hampshire for the therapeutic
benefits it provides and to allow Health
Providers to include this form of
therapy in their Allied Health
Professions list for the purpose of
insurance
reimbursement in the last session when I
learned about the objections of the
chair to the idea of adding another
qualified form of therapy uh to approved
Insurance systems lists um I really
didn't know how to respond to that
concern in any meaningful way because I
think she was concerned that insurance
rates would go up by adding this
additional modality
um however it appears that having the
option of a particular modality in
addition to what is already in that list
doesn't mean that a patient will use
more services it merely means that they
will have the freedom to choose the
appropriate modality for what it is they
have as a condition for their particular
condition so in this way music therapy
has been proven to work in cases where
other therapies do not and these results
are scientifically based it's not merely
someone playing a guitar or recording
music without goal setting and a
purposeful expertise behind it it is
supporting a trained therapist in
defining a treatment plan that leverages
the power of music to meet patients
where they are to achieve specific goals
against stubborn impediments the fiscal
note mentions the cost associated with
having to add a person who administers
this program for the state there would
be an offset to that cost based on the
existing and future lure fees collected
every two years that would contribute to
the cost of music therapy LIC Ure
Administration I believe an objective um
to to this
salary uh should be met with the
understanding that the other salaries
now paid for other Allied Health
Professions are no more worthy than
music therapy if you have any questions
for me I'm happy to answer them
otherwise I would be happy to pass the
Baton to licensed music therapist
Marissa Scott uh for the next portion of
the
presentation are there questions from
committee representative laus um just if
you don't know if you know off hand
could you give us the Senate bill number
if if not could you please send it I'm
not able to find it on the search thank
you representative leus yes I am I don't
have it at hand but I will I will get it
and forward it to you we've been having
some trouble finding it which is why I
was a little equivocal about whether
there is one I have heard that he did
file it so I'm I'm when I find it I will
send it along thank you thank
you um before we hear from anyone else
I'd like to call T Miss Tina Kelly from
the oplc to give us some administrative
uh data thank you thank
you is
there sorry about that um I am here now
I just had a little glitch with the
internet good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee I'm Tina Kelly
from the office of professional lure and
certification
oplc um the office of professional liur
and certification does not um support
nor do they oppose this
bill um but we are we do have one area
of concern and which is
unclear when looking at page three line
14 it's states that the executive
director shall seek the advice of the
board for issues related to the
regulation of music therapy now all of
the boards under Allied Health are
independent boards and are not advisory
boards this um line is a little
confusing because we're not sure whether
it's a a independent board under Allied
Health or an Advisory Board to the
executive
director um and the only other thing is
that um I want to reiterate that on page
four it we're asking for a
full-time um labor grade 15 and in order
to um move forward with a another board
it would be imperative that we have um
an individual to help with the licensing
the administration of the board and all
of those types of um
duties with that said I'll take any
questions thank you repres pres
Pearson thank you madam
chair you uh you gave me a great segue
here we on uh page four about the
program Assistant two
position with the anticipated number of
folks looking to become licensed music
therapists be sufficient enough to cause
the workload in the office to require
another person or is this could this
realistically just be absorbed into the
current U folks that oplc is is
using um they're very good question and
um what I would say is that right now
with the number of people and the number
of lenses and the growth of those
lenses current staff at oplc is um
stretched actually to their limits so in
adding another board and more license
types that's another um set of
regulations it would be we would
definitely need that full-time
position so I if I could paraphrase the
person is not necessarily full-time in
order to support this particular board
but to also support the ongoing
activities of
oplc well in a way yes but um with this
particular board there would be somebody
would have to administer the board and
the way oplc is
restructuring they have a light a
renewal section they have an initial
licensure section they have administr to
administer the boards so it the work of
boards is more spread out but even with
the addition of that it's going to put
more strain on the already overburdened
um
staff thank you I follow follow up the
the the funds necessary to to establish
this position are going to come solely
from the licensing fees from the music
therapists or is this going to require
other licensing fees to go up a little
bit to to generate enough Revenue to
make this position
happen Okay I I do not anticipate that
that would happen what I anticipate is
we're still working out the fee
structure and how the fees are going to
be administered at
oplc but currently because they'd be
under Allied Health Allied Health shares
all those costs so um even though they
wouldn't bring in enough to cover
everything because of the way op um the
way Allied Health is structured all of
those fees go in together to um to be
utilized across those boards with that
said oplc is changing that fee structure
so OPC determines the fees and um I
would have to get get you information
from Lindsay Courtney on how exactly
that new structure is going to
look thank you representative Alo hi um
thank you for taking my question U I
have a question about one sentence in
the language but actually uh I just want
to go back and clarify the answer to the
last question was that a yes or a no
on which question sorry on on where the
resources are coming to pay uh for the
um
employee I'm not sure if that was a yes
or no I would not anticipate that fees
would be raised okay and and now if I
may get to the question that started me
um there's a sentence that reads the
bill prohibits the practice of music
therapy without a license but there is
no penalty and it's it's an interesting
sentence be it it um causes me a little
bit of concern from two sides of the
coin to opposite
directions uh one is that there's no
penalty so if someone is breaking this
law why should there be no penalty and
the other side of that really same
question is is this going to Bar the way
for uh an approach to well-being that
right now is accessible to every one uh
and their
acquaintances by making it necessary to
go to a board certified individual to um
to enjoy the
advantages to benefit from the
advantages of involvement in music could
I answer that I think that yeah someone
else other than Miss Kelly would be best
to answer that thank you yes please do
answer I I believe that in the last
session this question came up as well
that people were concerned that folks
who use music as a way to do all kinds
of good things would be in some way
prohibited because of the
acknowledgement that if someone is
purporting to be a licensed you know or
certified music therapist that they
actually have to be certified and I
think they're they're pretty much
mutually exclusive we're not talking
about somebody who knows how to play
guitar coming in like or Senator avard
coming in uh when the fourth graders
come up to Representatives Hall and play
guitar for them um it's they they're not
they're not the same thing music therapy
is a very particular uh modality of
therapy and so um I I don't I don't
think those two things would ever cross
no one who is a b a board certified
therapist would ever be concerned that
somebody was using music it's if someone
is um if someone is representing
themselves as someone who has the
training credentialing and expertise
that they do not have that they would be
concerned and I think that's why they
want the profession recognized for the
skills that it brings that are separate
from just someone who's a musician thank
you representative Lego you want follow
up yeah a follow on to that I'm I'm not
concerned about the um example that you
use either um I know that the police
aren't going to be kicking down the door
for someone playing the guitar but
there's a lot of gray area I'm concerned
about um uh person who needs a uh a
release a relief a diversion uh and an
acquaintance or a professional
acquaintance says uh pick up the
guitar uh I just think that there's gray
area in there that worries me some can
you speak to the the gray area a little
bit yeah I think I think you know I
think this most significant aspect of
this bill which is relevant to other
states that have already adopted this is
the ability for this modality of therapy
to be acknowledged as included under
insurance so that folks who are
professionally trained who can give
people relief under this form of therapy
are actually able to get paid somebody
who doesn't have that certification uh
and is not acknowledged as a as a
licensed and certified therapist would
not be able to qualify for that payment
um so uh I think there are probably
other people on the call who have more
familiarity with it because I'm not I'm
not in the profession um I learned about
it in the last time around and because
my constituent who asked me to put the
bill in is a licensed music therapist
and she's one of the people who's going
to be testifying today I think that
other people should should mention this
when they're testifying that would be
the easiest thank you for that thank you
all right
other are there other questions from
Miss
Kelly I see seeing none uh Marissa
Scott hello hello okay just making sure
that it works thank you um chairwoman
Maguire and members of the committee
thank you I'm vissa Scott and I speak to
you today as the New Hampshire music
therapy task force chair a female
business owner a board-certified music
therapist and a New Hampshire citizen
with five employees in my business
providing music therapy to over 2500
individuals in New Hampshire I would
like to highlight two important points
on the necessity of this bill first
increasing access to services and
protecting consumers from harm is the
second people seek music therapy for
many reasons reasons I've helped a child
with cerebral paly learn to feed himself
and also through the combination of a
therapeutic relationship and songwriting
I've helped a teen with depression cease
and prevent himself from continuing acts
of self harm but many people face
bureaucratic barriers preventing access
to music therapy
services you see private insurance
companies require the provider's license
number on the credentialing form for
reimbursement and as hundreds of calls
I've been told repeatedly that we can't
bypass this request for a license number
Medicaid has the same requirement and
with over 27,000 disabled individuals
enrolled who can't access services from
unlicensed providers and that number
doesn't even include abused and
traumatized children placed in foster
care yet referrals from licensed doctors
and social workers who know the efficacy
of music therapy continue to come in for
patients in need who can't access our
services I'm not asking you to Advocate
on our behalf to private or state
insurances or even get involved in the
reimbursement process insurance
reimbursement is not the intent of this
legislation but it is imperative that
you know the barriers that New Hampshire
consumers
face to my second point it might seem
hard to understand how music could cause
harm but I will explain music therapists
are explicitly trained to observe and
respond to a person 's responses to
music we continuously assess responses
and adapt our approach in the moment to
refrain from contraindicated practices
given the diversity of diagnoses we work
with Comprehensive and rigorous clinical
training and experience are necessary
and anyone attempting to provide music
therapy without the training and
credentials May pose serious risks to
consumers an example of this harm is
using music that's too complex for the
person's neurological system resulting
in agitation disregulation and even
possible seizure there's also the
potential of music to be triggering for
clients who've experienced trauma and
disorienting for clients with
Alzheimer's ineffective or lack of
trained therapist response can lead to
short and long-term psychological or
even physiological harm and in New
Hampshire we have individuals claiming
they provide music therap therapy to
these vulnerable populations yet they're
not educated clinically trained or
board-certified and no one regulates
their compliance with safety standards
that board music therapists are required
to comply with creating a state license
mandates individuals meet both state and
National standards when identifying
themselves as a music therapist to
Consumers and protects your most
vulnerable citizens so I urge you to
vote Yes for New Hampshire house Bel 209
and increase access to the medically
necessary evidence-based services that
music therapists provide and protect
your constituents from the potential of
harm that could be caused by untrained
persons thank you for your
support thank you are there questions
for the from the committee yes
representative Pearson thank you madam
chair
and thank you Mr Scott for taking my
question I've been in EMT in New
Hampshire for 20 years I got a a simple
question in regards to your statement
involving um adverse
reaction to to what level does a
certified music therapists intervene
medically in the event of a not a
psychological trauma but actually more
of a
physical reaction to to something that
occurs uh Beyond just activating the EMS
system uh I mean depending on the event
we would call
911 um we are not medically trained
professionals follow
up okay so so if I'm understanding you
correctly then this is this is your ex
the extent of this of this training
would be to Simply recognize that
something bad is happening and that the
person needs to call
911 is it is it simply that is it really
that simple no the extent would be that
we recognize when music is causing harm
when music is disrupting a person's
neurological system and that we need to
immediately Stop the Music Experience to
further prevent that person from
becoming disregulated disoriented or
reaching a point where they may
experience
seizure
um
okay other
questions representative Roy
can you hear me yes thank you thank you
for taking my question um if if you can
can you give us um a ballpark of of what
a session music therapy session might
cost a consumer currently out of
pocket sure um roughly about 80 to $100
per session for one hour session okay
thank you okay any other
questions yeah thank
you if you don't mind me picking that
piggybacking on what represented Roy
just asked that current cost that you
just mentioned the $80 $100 an hour
that's a cash deal or is that what is
build to insurance companies uh in
states that that do
license that would be
cash okay so the fee structure for
insurance carriers would be different no
it would be the
same excuse me Madame chair this
is yes um how much is it please can can
uh can you repay it for me
please yes the average would be in for
New England for New England music
therapists would be between 80 and $100
per session okay all right so thank you
very much uh I have a second question
Madame chair
you yes uh what type of instrument that
person have to choose an instrument or
you going
to uh give that person an instrument to
play well music therapy is a very active
music process um so both the client and
the therapist are making music um
clients of Music therapists don't need
any instrument background or um there's
no specific instrument that we would
always use it's really client preference
um it's based on client need the music
therapist assesses what the goal for
that person is whether it's a motor
skill or whether it's working on um self
expression or um social emotional skills
the music therapist would choose what
instrument and what kind of music and
how fast or slow the music should be all
of those elements of Music are decided
by the music therapist and they're based
on the client's need so it's dependent
on the individual we're working with all
right so thank you very much you're
welcome president Roy you had a question
I do thank you for taking another
question um if everyone else on this
committee is like me were were between
somewhere picturing you know um a couple
people playing Bongos and someone
listening to Beethoven um and I imagine
it's somewhere in between it's is there
a video or a link anywhere you could
send us where we could actually see a
music therapy session so we kind of
understand what we're talking
about Yes actually um WMUR has an
amazing Chronicle segment on M on music
therapy um in New Hampshire um that
would be a really good example I can
send that link to uh send to the house
email yeah that that would be great
thank you thank you very much for
that okay other
questions is that a
question okay uh that case thank you
very much Miss Scott I call Rebecca
gildia
hello yes there you
are
um Madam chairwoman members of the
committee my name my name is Rebecca
gild I'm a board-certified music
therapist living and working in New
Hampshire and I thank you for the
opportunity to speak in support of
hp29 today there are at least 40 music
therapists working in the state of New
Hampshire that may sound like a small
number but the impact of just those 40
music therapists is significant in 2019
New Hampshire music therapists worked in
67 different facilities and served at
least
2,841 individuals across the granite
state in settings such as early interv
ention special education day programs
Memory Care Behavioral Health units
eating disorder clinics and substance
use programs to name a few music
therapists are uniquely trained and
certified to work with clients in
domains such as attention and cognition
attachment socialization emotional
processing and expression expressive and
receptive communication and mobility and
physical
rehabilitation music therapists use
evidence-based practices to work toward
each client centered goal supported
through a body of research spanning
decades the evidence of the positive
effects of music therapy has grown so
much that the National Institutes of
Health has awarded $20 million toward
research on music therapy and
Neuroscience over the next five
years the education training and
certification of a music therapist is
expansive and rigorous a music therapist
must earn a bachelor's degree or higher
the curriculum including coursework in
music human development psychology
anatomy and physiology and Behavioral
Sciences through this diverse course of
study a student learns how to use the
elements of Music the relationship
between the therapist and client and the
act of musicing itself as a means of
meeting specific measurable and
appropriate goals for their
clients after their classes a student
must earn a minimum of 1,200 hours in
supervised experience in a clinical
internship at the completion of their
academic and clinical training students
are eligible to take the board
certification exam and earn the
credential music therapist board
certified or mtbc which is a national
standard to demonstrate continued
competence and maintain this credential
music therapists are required to
complete 100 hours of continuing
education every five
years music therapy is an established
evidence-based and efficacious practice
that is serving the citizens of the
grandate state by creating a state
license for music therapists you will be
the governing body that upholds our high
standards of practice thereby protecting
your constituents from non-certified
practitioners that do not have this body
of experience in education in addition
you will be creating a state standard
that is comprehensive and accessible to
the public ensuring a transparent
process for New Hampshire citizens to
find a qualified and licensed music
therapy provider finally you will be
removing barriers to much needed
Services recognizing music therapists in
the state alongside their peers in
related professions and providing an
Avenue for job growth throughout the
state today I sh share my support of
hb29 and ask you to vote Yes for a music
therapy license in New Hampshire and if
I have a moment I would love to Circle
back to a question that was asked
earlier um about the difference between
music therapy and someone using music
therapeutically do I have time to do
so yes please do answer that question
sure music therapists do not do not own
music we do not own the therapeutic uses
of Music there are plenty of counselors
in healthcare there are plenty of um
occupational therapists and speech
therapists who utilize music in their
sessions as a way to work toward their
specific goals as well we don't own the
use of music as a way to work toward
therapeutic goals what we're asking with
this lure is to clarify that someone
claiming to be a licensed music
therapist or a B board-certified music
therapist has the credentials that
they're claiming that they have
currently there are people in our state
that say that they're providing music
therapy services and they are not
licensed or they are not board certified
they also do not have the education or
the training people like to use the word
therapy or therapeutic really Loosely to
anything that feels good or has worked
for
them and so a lot of people combine
music therapy in a very um casual way to
say that they're using music
therapeutically for themselves again
that's not a bad thing I want everyone
to access music and um experience
positive effects from it what we are um
trying to get across is that the
profession of music therapy is a is a an
established and protected profession and
that we're saying if you are claiming to
be a therapist a music therapist you
have the education and the credentials
and the um clinical education that
supports what you're telling people
you're capable of doing
thank you very
much representative Le you have a
question I do thank you um so when you
say a board certified music therapist
and they're being concerned that they
may claim to be a not be you tell me two
things one is what's involved becoming
board certified what does that mean and
number two um if someone claims to be
board certified is their way a potential
customer could determine whether they
were in fact board certified
so the to become board certified is um
what I testified about that education at
least a bachelor's degree a um a 1200
hour uh clinical supervised uh
clinically supervised internship and
then sitting for the national board
certified exam um and passing that board
then to maintain that board
certification 100 hours of uh continuing
ed every 5 years
um and that is similar those standards
are similar to other professions in the
um uh in the Allied Health
Professions um and in order to so to
claim that you are an mtbc music
therapist board certified you have to
have those um that background for a
consumer to check so someone can call
themselves a music therapist and not
disclose that they are board certified
or not board certified
uh because we have no lure in our state
or anything holding us back from that or
holding someone back from that um
a a consumer could find out if they're
uh if the person claiming to be a music
therapist uh by going to the board
certification uh website which is
cbmt dorg which is our certifi our
nationally accredited certification
Agency on their website you will find a
list of every single board certified
music therapist and the state that they
work
in follow um given that it's not clear
to
me um you know why there would be a need
for licensing specific to New Hampshire
um you know assuming unless unless you
believe the board certification process
is
inadequate um it's not clear why that
wouldn't be an adequate way for someone
to determine if the person they're
considering hiring uh you know has had
that kind of training sure um so yes
that is one protection our board
certification we do believe is adequate
for the standards that we practice by
the reason for lure has is
three-fold being a governing body you
are asserting that these professionals
are up to the standards that they're
claiming to be similarly to the reason
that you um that you license
Occupational Health the reason that you
um sort or license speech therapists the
reason that you um licensed massage
therapists in uh the state of New
Hampshire secondly as Marissa's
testimony
highlighted in order to work with um
insurance companies and uh Medicaid they
require State licensed professionals um
to even begin the conversation and so
without a state license where we are um
relegated to working with any either
private pay individuals which is um a
huge barrier for so many vulnerable
populations and and or grant funding
which comes and goes um and a lot of a
lot of our clients their services get
interrupted because the lack of funding
or a cut off at some point to grant
funding when these are medical um
medically
necessary this is a medically necessary
treatment for that person um as
evidenced by the referrals from medical
professionals or psychological
professionals okay thank you
representative
Roy thank you for taking another
question you um you just mentioned how
music uh you don't own music or or its
use and you mentioned how in a couple
different professions or settings um
music might be applicable to to some
treatments how is it then that this bill
would
not um make those people run a foul of
the new licensing
requirement for example if a
psychiatrist um plays some music in the
background or or a child therapist
somehow plays some music but without
calling it music therapy per se would
they not then be in violation of the new
licensing statute
no no they would not be um they on page
two starting with line nine it
specifically exempts other licensed
professionals who incidentally have
music involved
in thank you Madame chair thank
you other
questions okay thank you very much I'm
sorry I have one representative Pierce
um Miss Rebecca you and uh Miss Scott
have both indicated that you're
certified music therapists are you are
you licensed in another state or is is
your certification that you speak of
through the accreditation process of the
entity that representative leus
mentioned it's the second um we are
certified through our national boards uh
which is a national certification and we
live and work in New Hampshire so we are
not working in another state that
requires lure gotcha thank
you okay thank you very much I'd like to
call Neil
seia hello can you hear me yes you hear
you hi good afternoon uh chairperson
Maguire members of the committee and
attendees I'm Neil teer I'm the vice
president of governmental Affairs for
the New Hampshire speech language and
hearing
Association um we are a nonprofit
professional association and a state
level affiliate of the American speech
language and hearing
Association um currently there are over
900 um American speech language and
hearing Association certified members in
the state of New
Hampshire uh we work with an advocate
for students professionals and consumers
on issues related to speech language and
hearing sciences and we are licensed
under the Allied Board of Health here in
in New
Hampshire um were the committee members
able to look at the letters that were
sent to them from the New Hampshire
speech language uh and hearing
Association member Vicky chesterly and
the American speech language and hearing
Association president uh aen Williams
yes we received
them thank you
so I am here uh to testify today on our
organization's opposition to House Bill
209 as written um although um the New
Hampshire speech language and hearing
Association um does not oppose the
notion of Music therapist being licensed
for sure uh we have some concerns
regarding the language of the bill as is
as it is written as and as it pertains
to the scope of practice um furthermore
I would be more than happy to offer some
input on some additional language um
that might be considered to be added to
this
bill um and the other thing I wanted to
say is um mention in both the letters
that were sent and received by the U the
committee um we are requesting the
additional language to address um
treatment uh parameters Visa V music
therapists and communication disorders
um in the uh language currently um and I
believe that's um
line five um this the last sentence the
practice of music therapy does not
include the screening diagnosis of
assess or assessment of any physical
mental or communication disorder um I
would propose our our organization would
propose um that added to that um would
be or treatment of a communication
disorder the services of a music
therapist shall not replace the services
of an audiologist or a LIC licensed
audiologist or a licensed speech
language pathologist
um and the uh other area that was of
some
concern uh and the American speech
language and hearing Association our
affiliate National affiliate um
recommends as well and we concur that
music therapists uh shall collaborate
with um and discuss um the music therapy
treatment plan with the audiologist or
speech language pathologist of a client
with a communication
disorder
thank you any of members have any
questions for
me are there
questions there's a hand
raised representative Schmid you have a
question I do Madam chair thank you very
much uh Mr T for being with us today um
so uh were you involved in the process
last term when we uh when we heard this
bill
previously um I did send a letter to the
committee I believe uh when it was
um uh bear with me it
was House Bill
1286 it's a previous version um yeah um
I wasn't involved in the committee but I
did send of input to the process thank
you for having done so may I Madam chair
so as you were aware this is uh this
bill has uh has had interaction with uh
with your Association and with your
members uh in the previous go around
because of of a concern on on on your
your part I don't mean you specifically
but you know your profession your
Association has had a concern of a you
know an improper balance or interaction
between music therapists and speech
pathologists and so forth which the
previous
subcommittee uh you know worked to uh to
uh modify the language of the B the
proposed Bill last time in order to
resolve those issues and I and there
were some uh some amendments brought
with regard to the language uh that um
uh you know that was in the original
Bill uh have you seen that
have you seen the the results of that
interaction um I believe uh from reading
it it looks as though that there was
that specific language put in um that uh
let me just get to it I'm sorry excuse
me yes I believe that representative
McGee should be more appropriate to
address this because is this bill the
same as what was amended by the house
last term or is it uh what was initi
initially proposed to the
house
cat I I agree representative McGee C
certainly should weigh in on this um
because we want to those of us who are
proponents of music therapy uh lure in
the state of New Hampshire we do want to
resolve these issues because we don't
want to create a situation where music
therapists are stepping in your on your
toes or you
are in prohibiting or or Banning uh
preventing them from from practicing
their trade their profession um in a way
that's appropriate for them we want to
resolve these issues so that both sides
uh can can go forward in in in assisting
uh affected individuals in the state of
New Hampshire uh to to be to be
benefited to be cured to be to be helped
by your profession and music therapy as
well so that language situation is one
where I don't know if this is going to
go to a subcommittee but but if it does
uh we would certainly like to have your
involvement if representative McGee
can't clarify that not it well
representative McGee if you could report
to us what the status is of the
Amendments that were discussed and
adopted last year I would very much
appreciate it we don't need to discuss
it here
uh representative SCH do you have a
question well just I think she's I spoke
to her last night about her bill she
also is concerned at her committee about
executing so I did text her here she
comes there she
is yes representative McGee thank you we
had a question as to whether this is the
as introduced version of the bill from
last session or the as amended by
Edna my understanding what I asked OSS
to do was to incorporate the most recent
Amendment so it should be that and I
thank you very much I went and checked
for representative lakus uh in the
Senate bill um system and I do not see
the music therapy lure Bill filed under
uh senator aar's name so yes I found out
from talking to some Senators that they
have not yet released all their bills so
it's possible it's still going through
the system
okay that's great thank you for that all
right is that all you need because we're
start thank you very much are there
other
questions well I wasn't quite done Madam
chair so I'd pref prefer an opportunity
to continue question yes my question is
uh you know we we worked with several of
your uh professions Representatives last
time and we can't it seemed like we had
reached an accommodation where the
language of our bill was was changed
sufficiently so that uh your the the
lady from your
organization uh from your profession was
okay with that and we could proceed uh
with it and and and so I'd like to get
to that point with you as well yes um
could I speak of course I'm asking you
the question okay okay good I just don't
want to interrupt um again um I'll
reiterate that uh we and New Hampshire
speech language and hearing Association
aren't averse to the notion of lure for
music therapist nor are we averse to the
presence or the existence of Music
therapists I've worked alongside of
Music therapists over the course of my
20 plus years doing this
um it was the language around um
diagnosis and treatment um diagnosis uh
an assessment and and U screening has
been addressed in the language but the
treatment has not um that was concerning
to us uh and you know the previous
speakers have talked about the need for
licensure to protect the public um and I
think it is I agree with them I think
it's important for the public to know
that when there is a
communication impairment that speech and
language Pathologists are the licensed
professionals um to treat to diagnose
and treat those things um and I want to
assure the public that there is that
delineation between the two professions
um so that's why
we're um pushing for the change or the
additional language that addresses the
treatment of communication
disorders thank you we'll work on that
thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
Mr T teamer I'd like to called Heather
young hello hello hi thank you um my
name is Heather young I am live in
Rochester my husband and my two children
and um I am in support of House Bill 209
and I'm hoping you will be too um my son
Lucas is 10 years old uh I did send in
some written testimony earlier I hope
you were able to see it and see the
picture along with it that helps to put
a face to a name um Lucas has been
involved in music therapy his whole life
he's an active boy who loves basketball
making people laugh and anything that
has to do with music it's his number one
motivator um he's been through some
significant trauma in his life and um
multiple medical procedures uh more than
um in his short life while in the
hospital music therapy was always the
one thing that gave us his first smile
coming out of
anesthesia um music therapy helped him
take his first steps following his
tracheostomy procedure when he was
sedated for more than two weeks and we
brought our 5-year-old boy home as an
infant uh not being able to walk again
um music therapy was the one thing that
always pulled him out of it um we saw
such great progress with music y in the
hospital that we as a family were
committed to doing whatever we needed to
in order for this to become part of his
weekly Services Lucas does receive
occupational physical and speech therapy
for multiple sessions each week both
privately and in the school setting uh
these are all therapies that are covered
by his medical insurance that we provide
privately um for him as well as through
the Katie Becket waiver the therapy that
he makes the most progress in and has
always is his music y That's
unfortunately not a covered benefit uh
despite this being medically necessary
for his overall uh growth and
development um it's not seen as a
licensed profession in the sense of the
in the eyes of the insurance um and so
insurance will not cover it um if we
could get music therapy covered as a
benefit it could just help to um support
the other therapies that he does and
integrate them all together so that we
can have his biggest motivator along
with some of the things uh that are most
challenging for him currently we do have
to pay out of pocket for this essential
service um he's been at risk multiple
times of losing it as two as a two uh
full-time income family it's still a
struggle sometimes and it's kind of
always a first thing on the chopping
block because we all have priorities
that we have to do and we've always
found a way to make this a priority and
keep it um we have been committed for
paying out of pocket for over four years
for this for Lucas um and we have worked
with the same music therapist this whole
time So for anybody who's familiar with
therapies our children uh Lucas does
have Down syndrome and autism with ADHD
um our children go through multiple
therapists in all of the different
professions and we've been really lucky
to have the same therapist from the
beginning that still currently works
with him and pushes him even more um
every week that he sees her so the cost
is unsustainable as a family long term
and the passage of House Bill 209 will
help us to be able to get the coverage
um through the medical insurance that we
we pay for each year for him uh to help
him receive these essential services and
ultimately others who cannot afford to
pay for it out of pocket again we're
really fortunate for that um but it is a
high cost so we are in support of this
we hope you will be in support of it um
to help not only Lucas but others in the
state receive such essential services
thank you will you take some questions I
could certainly
try thank you representative Roy um
thank you Mr Young for taking my
question um we've heard some testimony
regarding the cost of these sessions as
proposed uh from previous Witnesses but
I wonder if you would mind sharing what
what your cost has been um per session
for this out of Pock sure so Lucas has a
30 minute session uh he is he could
certainly sustain more but um I believe
uh out of pocket we do have it privately
in our home so the therapist comes out
to our home I believe it's around um $50
for the session and then an additional
cost for the travel thank you very much
half an hour session thank you very much
other
questions thank you very
much wel thank
you patient
King
you have to unmute
yourself okay can you hear me now yes
thank
you Madame chairwoman members of the
committee
my name is Kisha King a board certified
music therapist representing music
therapists in New
Hampshire additionally I'm an Adjunct
professor of music therapy at my alma
moer Anam Maria College in central
Massachusetts when I decided to study
music therapy I discovered that New
Hampshire does not have any music
therapy degree programs in the state
going to college I learned that many
people relocate to their college towns
or the state that their college was in
and do not return to their home
communities according to research done
by economic modeling State University
graduates are most likely to permanently
live within state lines and 40% of those
students live within 50 miles of their
alma
mater prospective music therapists from
New Hampshire are required to relocate
for their education and often do not
come back it is clear that there is a
need for music therapy services in our
state and who would be better at
addressing those needs than people born
and raised
here in 2014 Rhode Island passed a music
therapy lure Bill similar to HB 209 and
in the fall of 2020 the University of
Rhode Island welcomed its first class of
music therapy students while there are
currently no music therapy degree
programs in the state of New Hampshire
this bill will provide new opportunities
in the state for practitioners and
patients and in the years to come we
hope that young people will have the
opportunity to study in their home state
bringing their knowledge and experience
to our New Hampshire
communities along with access and
improved awareness of music therapy will
come a need for qualified
practitioners according to the US Bureau
of Labor Statistics the job growth
outlook for counselors and social
service specialists is 14% in the next
five years and 25% more mental health
therapists and providers will be needed
in the coming years which greatly
exceeds the average 4% growth for other
fields the need for music therapists in
New Hampshire will only continue to grow
and along with that need will come a
need for affordable access to care which
as you've heard is not being
met my clients greatly benefit from the
unique modality of Music the therapy
often families are challenged to stretch
their limited funding so they can access
Services even if only for a short time
although my clients have adequate Health
Care coverage music therapy cannot be
covered due to lack of practitioner
licensure music therapists have met all
of the requirements by our national
governing boards but State lure is a
barrier that stands between our clients
getting the services they need for
provided to them for a reasonable fee
through their health
insurance in closing I ask that you vote
Yes for New Hampshire
hb29 establishing a music therapy
license in New Hampshire will allow more
consumers to access music therapy
services potentially increasing
education opportunities for future music
therapists and absolutely increased job
opportunities in this state thank you
for your
support thank you are there questions
from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you very much Nicole
Ali hello and thank you for taking the
time uh my name is Nicole om Al and I am
not a New Hampshire resident I'm here
testifying um I'm from Rhode Island I am
the government relations representative
and the chair of the task force where
similar legislation was passed so I'm
here to try to provide Clarity on the
impact of lure um from our state's
organization I do not want to be
redundant on what's already been said um
I do know and can also testify to the
risks of um well-intended misinformed
musicians practicing as music
therapists um and increasing Equitable
access of music therapy to vulnerable
populations that occurs with legislation
since our legislation passed we have had
an increase in jobs we also did um start
a degree program at a State University
um started to explore insurance
reimbursement which was not even an
option or up for conversation prior to
um The
Lure and um I also wanted to touch on um
the opposition from Asha as we also
faced this um we as music therapists um
we do not as was discussed claimed to
diagnose clients we do treat and if we
were to remove treatment um you know
sometimes we're not able to collaborate
with a speech therapist for a number of
reasons I can personally speak to a few
cases where a client was discharged from
speech therapy because they were no
longer making adequate progress they had
plateaued we were able to provide
evidence-based music therapy
interventions focusing
on language and then we referred them
when they started making progress again
back to speech therapy um and they were
able to continue to make progress um so
again that would be a case where we
would not be able to work with one of
the speech therapists um this opposition
music therapists and speech therapists
have worked together collaboratively
alongside one another for a long time
and have rarely I rarely have as a
clinician have had any challenges with
um speech therapists I find the
opposition seems to be coming from a
political standpoint and um you know
when when we went through this
legislation um you know they talked
about about how we did not want to
create an oligarchy where one type of
service disenfranchised another um when
we're all out for the benefit of the
client um so in Rhode Island and I'm
happy to share it we defined a scope of
practice with the president of the Rhode
Island Asha chapter um we looked at you
know again we outlined Diagnostics we
outlined what goals might look like um
so that might be a Way Forward because
by eliminating treating it means that
anyone with a disorder of communication
or speech would not be able to access
music therapy so I would um personally
probably be concerned about that um I
also have I'm I also sometimes come and
approach as a as a caregiver I have
young children with medical needs and we
have actually been um in hospitals where
they have received um misrepresentation
of music therapy where we had
well-informed uh well-intended
misinformed musicians um try to you know
offer their services as music therapists
to my own children um and their
practitioners also now actually speak to
the harm that it caused they you know
stimulative sedative music um there's a
lot you can do as a music therapist with
these evidence-based interventions and
those evidence-based interventions also
have a counter um so just as a more
concrete example we know that music can
elicit um to decrease or increase
Cravings in substance use disorders um
you need a trained professional that
knows what those parameters are in order
to make sure they decrease not increase
um so I appreciate your time again I I'm
trying to skip through what's already
been said and try to focus on what um
might be helpful from my professional
experience and
expertise thank you for your time thank
you very much are questions from the
committee yes yes of course
representative Schmid thank you very
much Madam chair and thank you also Miss
Ali for being here to speak with us uh
are you able to provide us with some uh
written material in support of your uh
testimony sure um I did provide a
written testimony but if there's
something specific you're looking for my
email is on that and I'm happy to
provide anything additional that would
help the committee well the reason I ask
is because because you're um your your
testimony has has has filled out a lot
of gaps I think that I and my colleagues
may have had with regard to uh some of
the aspects of music therapy because
it's not so obvious to somebody who is
not uh you know in the field or hasn't
had a child that has benefited from
music therapy uh to visualize exactly
what's going on and how it works and why
this helps that or doesn't help this or
this method method of doing it works and
that doesn't uh so the your testimony
has been much more concrete than we have
heard in some instances before and we
need to have that I think so to the
degree that you can provide it that
would be
helpful I believe the WR testimony was
already provided to us okay I I haven't
seen it so I'm glad to hear that and for
anyone that um it would be helpful my
daughter is now nine and she recalls her
experience and has
um I videoed her response so I'm happy
to provide my nine-year-olds testimony
as well for anyone who might thank you
that would be
special okay other
questions thank you very much and uh
Victoria
chesterly
yes you'll have to unmute miss
chesterly a okay did that work yes thank
you very much great thank you I'm the um
Madame chairwoman and members of the
committee I am the past president past
vice president of governmental Affairs
for the New Hampshire speech language
hearing Association and I was in on the
hearings last
year and the bill the Amendments the
changes to the this bill from last bill
are excellent we just wanted a little
bit more um
Neil toia covered most of what I would
say but I would also like to just um
make a few points one being for an
activity to be therapeutic there has to
be a treatment plan there have to be
goals there have to be reasons while
you're doing that specific activity
um
the you can't for for example if I was
reading to a
two-year-old okay I'm reading to a
two-year-old could I call that speech
therapy no not without or language
therapy not without specific reasons why
I'm reading that
specific um children's literature for
example
and I have some idea of why I'm doing it
um so I could use music in doing speech
and language therapy but my goalss would
be speech and language goals they
wouldn't be music therapy
goals does that answer a question that
came up
earlier
about untrained music the people who are
untrained and calling themselves music
therapists can go in and play the guitar
but that's not not therapy because they
don't
have the
um structure around the
activity we're not opposed to um
licensing music
therapists we just want to
clarify
the parameters of what they do and what
we do and we would we do work together
I'd be very interested in what um Rhode
Island had worked out in terms of their
bill and how
that made it more clear
um my concern one of my concerns is that
if the public thinks that music
therapists are treating communication
disorders will they actually get the
speech and language therapy that they
need who knows know
um
otherwise we would like the bill to
address treatment of the underlying
communication
disorders um Miss Scott mentioned that
they work on expressive and receptive
language
okay but they need to they don't have
the training in language development
that speech and language Pathologists do
also
um oh yes Miss Ali brought up the issue
of Consulting with the speech and
language pathologist if someone is not
receiving speech and language
therapy while they're receiving music
therapy they don't need to consult with
the speech language
pathologist it's only when both
activities are going on at the same time
and it's important that all thies work
together Physical Therapy occupational
therapy speech and language therapy and
music therapy that that wasn't
um I would think that an occupational
therapist would be interested
in what a music therapist was doing or a
physical therapist was doing as well but
we're only really concerned with speech
and language therapy and
Audiology I don't
know how much
um crossover there is between music
therapy and ideology but one example
that was given last year as could be
detrimental was that a non-trained a
person who is not trained as a music
therapist could be playing music too
loud for someone with hearing aids or
with someone with or for anyone but
specifically someone with hearing aids
would
be could be hurt by
that thank you very much Miss cheser
okay are there any questions from the
committee looks like Neil might have a
question his hand was raised yes well
that's this is the time for the
committee to ask question oh okay
sorry don't see any okay thank you for
your time and understanding thank you
for your testimony is
there Mr teer you wish to speak
again
I if I could just briefly respond to a
couple of things um that one of the
speakers um I believe the woman from
Rhode Island I'm sorry Her Name Escapes
me but
um one of the things is I wanted to say
this is not a political um issue for our
organization not
whatsoever um I'm a New Hampshire
resident have been for over over three
decades um I attended the University of
New Hampshire for my graduate work in
speech language
pathology
um one of the things that concerned me
was the idea or the notion that there if
there's not a speech language
pathologist available they can work on
those things and she
um alluded to that in her uh testimony
but I would say I work with clients all
the time where perhaps they're eliciting
a fine motor or a gross motor
problem and that's really the domain of
the physical therapist or the
occupational therapist um in the absence
of there one being an OT or a PT
available I would not pursue working on
fine motor or gross motor simply because
of there's an absence of that and that
the person certainly needs that help um
I stay within my scope of practice and
we have a very broad scope of practice
mind you but nonetheless there are
parameters and borders that I do not
cross as a
professional um so just because the
orthodontist is not available the
hygienist doesn't apply the braces um it
just doesn't get done
unfortunately um as far as safety is
concerned again and Victoria um did
mention this but I'll just re re recast
it um that we can't have patients with
communication disorders or impairments
seeking assistance
from clinicians or therapists that are
not trained to the degree or that we
are we specialize in these communication
impairments this is how we're trained
with very extensive training that
training was laid out in the letters
that we sent to the the committee
um and I think in terms of in the name
of Public Safety we would we would not
want somebody that's not adequately
trained or competent to do that to have
the ability to do that and that's why we
uh request that that treatment um
language be put in there and I would be
happy to work with the committee uh if
they so choose to wish for my help um in
helping uh um collab orate with that
Committee in um the
language thank you we'll let you know
when when and if there is such a meeting
thank you very much for having me the
opportunity to
speak is there anyone else who wish oh
representative Shu you have a
question yes Madam chair I do thank you
a question just occurred to me for uh
perhaps Mr
demia um or one of the speech language
pathologists I'm curious if there is
ever an instance where someone in that
profession would in fact refer a client
to a music
therapist um I would answer yes to that
um and that would be our ethical and
clinical U obligation if we're working
with a client and we see that that
client has a need or could benefit
uh from a type of therapy that we are
not um competently uh or legally able to
provide uh we would and we do we make
referrals all the time I refer out to um
you know I mean I've worked across you
know from my internships at Catholic
Medical Center in the ICU and CCU uh you
know we work uh you have speech
pathologists working there working with
people on on endot tral tubes getting
them safe and ready to swallow food
again um to working with students in a
school to working in my private practice
I have worked across pretty much all
settings nursing homes hospitals um and
so I've worked with a lot of therapists
OTS pts music therapists dietitians um
there's a lot of people on the medical
team and um certainly uh referring out
to the appropriate clinician when we see
that there may be a need for that um is
certainly something we do yes
thank you who has a questiones represent
you have a
question yes thank you Madame
chair the bill from last year the issue
this this really the Crux of this bill
is um G is having the music therapist be
paid by insurance I was on a
subcommittee that involved this um Bill
last year and I think we noodled out all
the issues that the speech therapist had
with the music therapist on this
issue can you please confirm
that who is a question for I apologize
it's either for Mr themia or I guess it
would be M Mr themia yeah okay thank you
um as Mrs chesterly had said uh prior um
that the collaboration with the
committee on the previous house bill I
think it was
1286 uh was previous form um we we did
um rais concerns and and had input and
uh we appreciate that the committee did
make changes to that um I think really
the only change that I would be
requesting that hadn't been made I say
me but the organization in which I
represent um would be the um language
around the treatment um again uh and the
reason or rational behind that would be
simply if if the consumer that is the U
patient client uh is uh seeking help for
communication and pment that uh they
need to be directed to the clinicians
that are trained specifically in
communication impairments and disorders
which is what speech language
Pathologists do that is the primary
focus of what we
do thank you are there other questions
question from the
committee seeing none is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on House Bill
20 all right thank you all very much I'm
closing the
hearing we will not be voting on this
bill
today is there any enthusiasm for voting
on any other bills
okay in that case we we are resuming
again on Thursday
morning thank you for your patience and
I will see you
then